NO APRIL FOOLS DAY JOKES TODAY
PLEASE -- WE HAVE NINE BILLS ON
THE FILE TODAY. TO MEASURES --
ARE PROPOSED FOR CONSENT.
FILE ITEM NUMBER SEVEN AND FILE
ITEM NUMBER.
NINE AT THE REQUEST OF THE
AUTHOR.
FILE ITEM NUMBER SIX HAS BEEN
PULLED.
I DON'T SEE A QUORUM PRESENT YET
SO -- UNLESS THERE'S OBJECTION
WILL BEGIN -- AS A COMMITTEE OF
THE WHOLE.
AND LIKE TO INVITE UP CENTER
WIENER. TO PRESENT HIS FIRST
BILL -- SB. THIRTY FOUR SENATE
LEADER YOU'RE WELCOME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MISTER CHAIRMAN I WANT TO THANK
YOU AND YOUR STAFF FOR WORKING
WITH US.
ON THIS BILL AND I'M HAPPY TO
ACCEPT THE OCT.
MEN'S RECOMMENDED BY THE
COMMITTEE -- COLLEAGUES SB --
THIRTY FOUR WILL ALLOW DONATION
BASED.
COMPASSIONATE CARE MEDICAL
CANNABIS PROGRAMS -- TO CONTINUE
TO EXIST IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
OUR COMPASSIONATE CARE PROGRAMS
ARE PROGRAMS WHERE -- SOMEONE
OFTEN A COOPERATIVE WERE A
BUSINESS THAT DOES IT ON THE
SIDE -- WILL DONATE -- MEDICAL
CANNABIS FREE OF CHARGE TO LOW
INCOME -- PATIENTS PEOPLE WHO
RELY ON MEDICAL CANNABIS TO
TREAT I HIV CANCER GLAUCOMA OR A
VARIETY OF OTHER ISSUES -- THESE --
ARE A LOT OF DIFFERENT KINDS OF
PEOPLE INCLUDING MANY VETERANS --
INCLUDING OUR CHILDREN WHO ARE
VERY VERY SICK AND CANNABIS IS
THE ONE WAY THAT THEY ARE ABLE
TO STAY.
HEALTHY -- WITH FEE -- OF THESE
PROGRAMS PARTICULARLY IN MY
COMMUNITY -- WERE INSTRUMENTAL
IN HELPING MY COMMUNITY --
SURVIVED THE WORST OF HIV AIDS
EPIDEMIC UNFORTUNATELY THESE
PROGRAMS ARE -- DYING AND
THEY'RE BEING KILLED OFF BECAUSE
WHEN -- PROP SIXTY FOUR PASSED
ON THE VOTERS I BELIEVE IN
CURRENTLY IMPOSED -- TAXES --
BOTH CULTIVATION AND USE TAXES --
ONLINE -- OF FREE OF CHARGE
DONATED -- COMPASSIONATE CARE OP
PROGRAMS.
THESE PROGRAMS OF COURSE HAVE NO
REVENUE BECAUSE THEY'RE THEY'RE
NATION BASED -- AND THAT MEANS
THEY HAVE NO WAY OF PAYING A AND
SO THEY'RE GOING AWAY -- WE IT
SHOULD BE EMBRACING AND
SUPPORTING THESE PROGRAMS NOT
KILLING THEM OFF AND SO SB --
THIRTY FOUR WILL -- EXAMS --
THESE ARE PROGRAMS ARE FROM THE
APPLICABLE -- STATE TAXES --
WE'VE MENDED THE BILL -- TO NAME
AT THE DENTIST CORONA BROWNIE
MARY ACT WHO WERE TO HEROES IN
OUR COMMUNITY IN SAN FRANCISCO
WHO WERE SOME OF THE PROGENITORS
OF THE MEDICAL CANNABIS MOVEMENT --
SO I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE.
AND WITH ME TODAY ARE KRISTEN
I'VE NEVER DAHLE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF INTERNATIONAL
CANNABIS AND FARMERS ASSOCIATION --
AND SHAUN KAREN AND WITH WEED
FOR WARRIORS ARE BETTER -- BASED
COMPASSION PROGRAM THANK YOU
THANK YOU CENTER WINNER AND
BEFORE WE BEGIN WITH YOUR
TESTIMONY IN FAVOR.
OF MENTION FOR COMMITTEE MEMBERS
AND FOR MEMBERS OF THE AUDIENCE
THAT THE PRACTICE OF OUR
COMMITTEE THIS YEAR IS TO
PROVIDE SIX MINUTES.
I'D TESTIMONY IN FAVOR AND AN
EIGHT AND AGAINST AND COULD BE
IN COMBINATION OF WITNESSES --
THEIR OF SO I JUST TO BE AWARE
OF THOSE PRACTICES AND I WELCOME.
TESTIMONY OF YOUR WITNESSES IN
FAVOR CENTER THANK YOU.
A GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
CHRISTINA BUT ALL 'M A LONG
TIME MEDICAL CANNABIS FARMER.
AM I WAS ONE OF THE CO FOUNDERS
OF THE EMERALD GROWERS
ASSOCIATION AND THEY SERVE FOR A
NUMBER OF YEARS AS THE DIRECTOR
OF PATIENT FOCUSED CERTIFICATION
WHICH IS A PRODUCT SAFETY
CERTIFICATION PROGRAM --
PRODUCED BY THE AMERICANS FOR
SAFE ACCESS.
I'M CURRENTLY I SERVE ON THE
BOARD OF DIRECTORS FOR THE
CALIFORNIA CANNABIS INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION I'M A CO FOUNDER AND
THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
INTERNATIONAL CAM AS FARMERS
ASSOCIATION.
AND I'M ALSO AN APPOINTEE TO THE
STATE'S CANNABIS ADVISORY
COMMITTEE -- IN SORT OF
DEDICATED MOST OF MY
PROFESSIONAL LIFE TO PROMOTING --
AT BEST PRACTICES FOR SOME GROWN
CANNABIS FARMERS BUT ALSO
STANDARDS FOR PRODUCTS SAFETY IN
THE MEDICAL CANNABIS IN THE
CONSUMER ROUND -- AND AS SENATOR
WIENER MENTIONED IN NINETEEN
NINETY SIX CALIFORNIA DID PASSED
PROPOSITION TWO FIFTEEN AND
WITHOUT PASSAGE WE SAW THE BIRTH
OF COMPASSIONATE CANNABIS
PROGRAMS TO HELP -- SICK
PATIENTS WHO UNFORTUNATELY
COULDN'T DIDN'T HAVE ACCESS TO
OUR COULD NOT AFFORD MEDICAL
CANNABIS TO SERVE THEIR NEEDS --
WITH THE PASSAGE OF PROPOSITION
SIXTY FOUR WE SAW A 15% EXCISE
TAX IMPOSED ON ALL MEDICAL AN
ADULT WHO'S TAP -- CANNABIS WE
ALSO SAW A SIGNIFICANT
CULTIVATION TAX.
AND AS MENTIONED THERE IS
CURRENTLY.
NO REPRIEVE -- FOR FOLKS TRYING
TO CARRY ON COMPASSIONATE
PROGRAMS THEY CANNOT ESCAPE THE
TAXATION -- AS CURRENTLY WRITTEN --
THIS IN COMBINATION WITH THE
VAST REDUCTION OF SAFE ACCESS
POINTS TO RETELL ENTITIES --
ALLOWED TO PROVIDE CANNABIS TO
PATIENTS.
HAS UNFORTUNATELY CREATED A
CRISIS AMONGST -- PATIENTS IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
THE OVER THE PAST YEARS SERVING
ON THE CALIFORNIA CANNABIS
ADVISORY COMMITTEE WE HAVE HEARD
REPEAT TESTIMONY FROM PATIENTS
AND VETERANS AND COMPASSION
GROUPS ABOUT THEIR INABILITY TO
SERVE.
THE NEEDS OF PATIENTS AND
PARTICULARLY IT'S THE NEEDS OF
THE MOST VULNERABLE PATIENTS --
SB THIRTY FOUR WOULD RECTIFY THE
SITUATION BY ELIMINATING THE TAX
ON HELPING TO MOVE THESE
PROGRAMS FORWARD -- AND I
RESPECTFULLY URGE AN AYE VOTE
TODAY ON BEHALF OF THESE
PATIENTS THAT NEED THIS BILL TO
PASS A DESPERATELY THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS SEAN KERN AND I'M A
SMALL PART OF THE WEEK FOR HIS
PROJECT.
WE ARE A GROUP OF VETERANS
FIGHTING IN THE TRENCHES AND
ADVOCATING. FOR OUR SISTERS AND
BROTHERS TO HAVE A CHOICE TO
MEDICATE WITH CANNABIS IN ORDER
TO TREAT THEIR MILITARY TRAUMA
AS AN ALTERNATIVE. TO THE
COCKTAILS OF PHARMACEUTICALS
CURRENTLY PRESCRIBED BY THE VA
THAT ALL HAVE ADDICTION OVERDOSE
AND SUICIDE AS STATED FTA RISK.
I WOULD BE REMISS IF I FAILED TO
MENTION THAT WE SUPPORT ACCESS
TO CANNABIS FOR EVERYONE.
SO WHILE WE ARE VETERANS
REPRESENTING JUST 7% OF THE
POPULATION WHO WEAR THAT TITLE
WE ARE FIGHTING FOR EVERYONE TO
HAVE THE FREEDOM OF CHOICE TO
CHOOSE WHAT MEDICINES.
THEY ARE ALLOWED TO USE OR PUT
INTO THEIR BODY.
WE THE PROJECT -- HERE TODAY TO
SUPPORT SB THIRTY FOUR AND WE
URGE EVERY SENATOR HERE TO LEND
THEIR SUPPORT.
SB THIRTY FOUR IS AN ON RAMP TO
CALIFORNIA'S LEGAL MARKET FOR
THE SICK.
DISABLED AND DISENFRANCHISED.
UNDER PROP SIXTY FOUR TO
CALIFORNIA'S FOR CANNABIS HAVE
BEEN CREATED. ONE FOR THOSE WITH
DOLLARS AND RESOURCES WERE ABLE
TO AFFORD THE TREMENDOUS COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH PRODUCING AND
MEDICAID IMPROPERLY.
AND THE OTHER THE ILLICIT MARKET
WHERE THE SICK POOR AND
DISENFRANCHISED HAVE BEEN FORCED
TO TURN.
IN THEIR HOPES OF AVOIDING
OVERDOSE ADDICTION AND SUICIDE.
HOUSE SO WE FOR WARRIORS
CONFRONTING THIS EPIDEMIC HEAD
ON THE WEED FOR WARRIORS
CONDUCTS MONTHLY MEETINGS
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA.
VETERANS SPEND THEIR MEETINGS
AND JOIN THE CONNECTIONS THAT
ANY BETTER WILL TELL YOU THEY
MISS.
THE OTHER PURPOSE OF THESE
MEETINGS IS DISTRIBUTE CANNABIS
TO QUALIFIED VETERANS WHO CAN'T
AFFORD TO PURCHASE THEIR
MEDICINE.
VA NOR INSURANCE COVERS MEDICAL
MARIJUANA AND FOR A 100%
DISABLED VETERAN THE THREE
THOUSAND A RECEIVING MONTHLY
DISABILITY PAYMENTS DOESN'T EVEN
COVER THE COST OF LIVING.
LET ALONE DISCRETIONARY INCOME
TO COVER CANNABIS VIA THE LEGAL
MARKET.
AS THE BETTER LEADERS BEHIND YOU
ABOUT THE MEETINGS THEY SEE
VETERANS AT THEIR MEETINGS
GRACIOUSLY ACCEPT THEIR BROWN
BAG OF DONATIONS.
THE PEER INSIDE TO SEE FLOWER
DONATED BY GROWERS WHEELS
DONATED BY MANUFACTURERS
VAPORIZERS DONATED BY
ENTREPRENEURS AND LOS IN SCHOOL
OF MEDICINE AT B. T. SWEAR BY.
SMILES PERMEATE THE FACES
SPOUSES ARE HAPPY KNOWING THEIR
MOM AND DAD'S ARE HAPPY.
THESE DAYS ARE GOOD DAYS A DAY
THAT IS IN DANGER OF BECOMING A
THING OF THE PAST FOR THESE
VETERANS.
UNDER PROP SIXTY FOUR ALMOST ALL
DONATIONS THE WEED FOR YEARS
PROJECT HAS HISTORICALLY
RECEIVED ARE OUTLAWED WITH GREAT
PERSONAL RISK TO ALL THOSE
INVOLVED.
IN DISCUSSION WITH WE FORCE
HISTORICAL DONORS.
THAT ARE LICENSED OR PURSUING A
LICENSE THROUGHOUT THE STATE ALL
OF THEM FROM GROWERS TO
MANUFACTURERS ARE NOW
PRAGMATICALLY UNABLE TO DONATE
MEDS OF ANY KIND.
WE ASK THAT YOU IN THE ELECTED
OFFICIALS OF CALIFORNIA STAND
WITH US AND DEMAND SOME RELIEF
FROM THE OVER REGULATION OF
CANNABIS.
WE OWE IT TO OUR VETERANS TO
SEEK RELIEF FROM THE FORCE OF
SERVICE WE OWE IT TO ALL OUR
COMMUNITIES WHO HAVE BEEN SO
DISPROPORTIONATELY TARGETED.
BY OUR WAR AGAINST CANNABIS WE
NEED TO Y. DOWN THE WAR WE HAVE
AGAINST THE POOR AND THAT DOES
NOT OCCUR.
BY REGULATING AND TAXING A PIVOT
AND LAW FORCING CROSSERS FROM
EVERYONE TO SQUARELY IN SOLELY
ON THE BACK OF THOSE NOT
PRIVILEGED ENOUGH TO BE
CONSIDERED GOOD ACTORS.
AS OUR STATE GOVERNOR CALLED
THOSE SERVING IN THE LEGAL
MARKET THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU LASHANDRA BEFORE WE
HEAR ME TOO THAT THE MICROPHONE
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL I THINK
WE HAVE A QUORUM BY PRESENTS A
LET'S ESTABLISH IT.
GLAZER HERE GLAZER HERE CHIANG
ARCHULETA.
AGILITY HERE DODD GALGIANI.
GALGIANI HERE HELL.
HELL HERE LEYVA.
LEYVA HERE PAN PAN HERE WELL.
WELL CARE.
VERY GOOD SO WE HAVE A QUORUM
AND WILL CONTINUE ONE SO IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO GIVE ME TOO AT THE
MICROPHONE IN FAVOR THIS BILL
PLEASE STEP RIGHT UP AND SURE
YOUR NAME AND AFFILIATION IF YOU
HAVE ONE AND AND YOUR INDICATION
SUPPORT.
HELLO MEMBERS MY NAME IS
ENTERING GRADSTEIN FROM NOR CAL
CANNABIS COMPANY AND WE ARE A
COMPANY THAT HAS CULTIVATION
RETAIL MANUFACTURING AND
DISTRIBUTION LICENSES HERE IN
THE STATE.
AND WE ARE HERE TO VOICE OUR
STRONG SUPPORT FOR THE BILL
TODAY VERY GOOD THANK YOU.
NEXT.
THE MORNING SAM RODRIGUEZ SOME
WE HAVE A LONG PULL VALLEY KIND
OF ASSOCIATION.
MANY OF US ARE GONNA MEMBERS ARE
FORMER VETERANS ONLINE WERE VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF THIS OF THIS BILL
AND WE ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE AND
WE WANT TO APPLAUD.
CENTERS GOT WIENER FOR HIS
EFFORTS THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS MILLIE
BONHOMIE W. ASKED ME LOCAL
THIRTY NINE THIRTY ON BEHALF OF
A HUNDRED TEN THOUSAND I JUST AS
PROVIDERS ACROSS -- TWENTY ONE
COUNTIES IN THE STATE WHERE AN
AWFUL SUPPORT OF THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
MY NAME IS WADE LAUGHTER WITH
HOUSE OF PARLIAMENT I'M HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE CLAD REASON
NETWORK.
OUR MISSION STATEMENT IS TO
PROVIDE EDUCATION AND IF
APPROPRIATE CANNABIS THERAPIES.
TO THE FAMILIES OF
CATASTROPHICALLY ILL CHILDREN AT
NO COST TO THOSE FAMILIES EVER.
PLEASE PHOTO BY ON SENATE BILL
THIRTY FOUR X. PERSON.
GOOD DAY.
FIRST OFF I'D LIKE TO THANK YOU
ALL FOR YOUR PARTICIPATION IN
OUR GOVERNMENT.
AND YOUR SERVICE IN THAT.
MORNING SPREAD HALL I'M
REPRESENTED ARE A MEMBER OF
WHEAT FOR WARRIORS.
I'D ALSO LIKE TO READ YOU A
QUOTE FROM FAVORITE QUOTE.
SIR THIS IS JUST AN OPT IN.
REAL QUICK UNFORTUNATELY BROKEN
TIMES FAVORITE QUOTE FROM THE
BIBLE [inaudible]
GENESIS.
NINE AS EVEN THE GREEN HERB I
GIVE UNTO YOU ALL THINGS.
I BELIEVE COMPASSIONATE CARE
SHOULD BE.
GOD GIVEN RIGHT THANK YOU MUCH
THANK YOU.
THE SACROILIAC OFFICIAL IMPACT
MANAGER FROM EASE TECHNOLOGIES
HERE IN SUPPORT OF SB THIRTY
FOUR THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS NEIL YARBOROUGH WHO
MARINE CORPS VET.
I WAS -- IN THE SERVICE FOR
THIRTEEN YEARS TO FIGHT FOR YOUR
FREEDOM.
EXPECT YOU GUYS TO HELP FIGHT
FOR OUR FREEDOM NOW -- IF IF IT
WASN'T FOR THE WE FOR YEARS AND
IN ORGANIZATIONS LIKE THIS.
I WOULDN'T BE HERE ALRIGHT SO
I'D LIKE YOU TO THINK ABOUT THAT
BEFORE YOU VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT VERSE.
HELLO MY NAME IS WATCHING US ON
THE LEADERSHIP OF STOCK
INSTRUCTORS OF WE FOR YEARS --
INCOMPLETESUPPORT OF THIS BILL
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR BEING
HERE.
HI I'M NEW YARBOROUGH'S WIFE AND
AS A SPOUSE.
LOOKING AT IT FROM BOTH SIDES AS
A SOLDIER AND A SPOUSE.
I WOULD HIGHLY RECOMMEND YOU
GUYS.
GO AHEAD WITH THIS BILL BECAUSE
I OF MYSELF HAVE BEEN THROUGH A
TRAUMATIC EXPERIENCES WITH HIM
BEING ON THOSE MENTAL HEALTH
PILLS SO.
I PLEASE HOPE THAT YOU GUYS
PASSED THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANKS FOR BEING A FEW.
HELLO MY THE WEEKLY -- TEN AFTER
ARMY THAT WAS POOR THIS BILL
WOULD FOR LAWYERS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
HELLO MATT HOW ON A MEMBER
OAKLAND CANNABIS REGULATORY
COMMISSION IN OUR COMMISSION
VOTED UNANIMOUSLY IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL AND WE ASK YOU TO DO
THE SAME THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS SAM KELSON I'M
A LAWYER WITH MCALLISTER
GARFIELD AND CALCIUM Là GROUP I
REPRESENT COMPASSIONATE CARE
PROGRAMS.
I'VE BEEN PART OF THE
DISCUSSIONS ON THAN THEY NEEDED
PROTECTION FOR COMPASSIONATE
CARE PROGRAMS SINCE THE STATE
HAD ADVISORY COMMITTEES LAST
JANUARY AND FEBRUARY I'M ASKING
THE TO MAKE THE COMMITTEE TO
FOLLOW IN STEP WITH WHAT THEY
DID IN THE LAST LEDGE CYCLE.
AND PLEASE SUPPORT THIS BILL SO
THAT WE CAN ENSURE THAT THE
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES IN
CALIFORNIA INCLUDING THE
VETERANS.
THAT LOW INCOME AND TERMINALLY
ILL.
HAVE ACCESS TO THEIR MEDICINE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS VANESSA AND I
WORK WITH MINORITIES FOR MEDICAL
MARIJUANA AND WE SUPPORT SB
THIRTY FOUR WE WISH THAT YOU DO.
TOO THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
BEING HERE.
GOOD AFTERNOON GOING BACK AS FOR
DRUG POLICY ALLIANCE IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON AMY JENKINS ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
CANNABIS INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION
AND COUNTY CRAFT IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
I JASON BRYANT GUMBEL COUNTY
GROWERS LINES WERE IN SUPPORT
THANK THANK YOU.
HI ANGIE MINETTI HERE ON BEHALF
OF CONTINUUM IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
RICHARD MANNING RESEARCH MARINE
CORPS WHICH FOR YEARS BUT FULLY
SUPPORTER THIS AMMO SERVERS AND
MY MOTHER LINDA MANNING.
WHO'S AT HOME AND SHE'S BETTER
AND SINCE SHE FULLY SUPPORTS
THIS BILL TO PLEASE THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS IDEAL AT EIGHT PM
A COMMUNITY ADVOCATE.
A FAMILY OF CLARGES NETWORKS MY
SON WAS DIAGNOSED WITH T. CELL
LEUKAEMIA GIVEN THREE DAYS TO
LIVE.
I LOST MY JOB AND BEING ABLE TO
SUPPORT BUYING CANNABIS ON OUR
OWN WE HAD A MORTGAGE OUR HOUSE.
CLASHES NETWORKS WERE ABLE TO
AFFORD IT IS GIVE MY SON HIS
CHILDHOOD BACK HIS LABS HE'S
ABLE TO EAT AND SLEEP SO PLEASE.
HAVE COMPASSION FOR THE NEEDY
AND WE SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK
YOU FOR BEING HERE.
MAR INTERNET ON BEHALF OF THE
UNITED CAN AS VNCE ASSOCIATION
SUPPORT THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
THE MEASURE FOR THANK YOU.
MAX NICHOLAS ON BEHALF OF
OPERATION EITHER I CAN FLOW CON
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
DEAL SHE FROM ONE OF THE
ATTORNEYS FOR WHEAT FOR WARRIORS
PROJECT AND DISABLED VET.
AND I URGE YOU TO VOTE I ON THIS
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS CLYDE CORNING AND A
MEMBER WHICH FOR WARRIORS.
IT WAS NOT FOR THAT PROGRAM I
WOULDN'T BE STANDING HERE
TALKING TO YOU I HAVE A GUNSHOT
WOUND TO THE BACK OF MY HEAD AND
YOU CAN STILL STICK YOUR FINGERS
THROUGH MY SKULL.
IT WASN'T THAT WE DOES SMOKE I
WOULDN'T BE HERE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ARE THERE
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN FAVOR.
ALL RIGHT ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
THE COMING UP.
I SEE THAT OKAY A SENSORS THAT
NO OPPOSITION WITNESSES WILL
BRING THE MATTER BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR DISCUSSION COMMA
MEMBERS ANY [inaudible]
COMMENTS [inaudible]
QUESTION.
A CENTER WE ARE GIVEN THE
OPPORTUNITY CLOSE.
OF CENTER ARCHULETA YES THANK
YOU MISTER I JUST WOULD LIKE TO
THANK US SENATOR -- FOR BRINGING
THIS FORWARD AS A VETERAN MYSELF
I THANK YOU INTO ALL THE
VETERANS WELCOME HOME AND THIS
IS OUR FIRST STEP FOR FOR US TO
SAY THANK YOU FOR YOUR SERVICE.
AND IDEA SUPPORT THIS BILL.
OTHER COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
SENATOR WE WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE I
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN I I
JUST WANT TO SAY THANK YOU TO
ALL OF THE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMUNITY INCLUDING PEOPLE
STRUGGLING WITH HEALTH
CONDITIONS.
WHO LAST YEAR CAME UP FOR EVERY
SINGLE HEARING ON THIS BILL AND
ARE NOW DOING IT AGAIN -- I'M
SORRY THAT THEY HAVE TO COME UP
AGAIN THIS BILL SHOULD HAVE BEEN
SIGNED INTO LAW TO LAW LAST YEAR
BUT SOMETIMES HE DOES HAPPEN --
SO I THINK WE'LL I HOPE HAVE A
BETTER RESULT THIS TIME I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
THANK YOU THANK YOU SENATOR
WIENER THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PERSISTENCE AND THOSE OF YOUR
MANY FRIENDS AND SUPPORTERS IN
THE COMMUNITY SOMETIMES THINGS
ON ALL HAPPN ON THAT.
TRACK THAT WE WOULD LIKE BUT I
APPRECIATE YOUR YOUR
THOUGHTFULNESS IN PREPARING HIS
BILL SOMETHING I'M CERTAINLY
PREPARED TO SUPPORT TODAY SO
WITH THAT I THINK SENATOR LEYVA
DID YOU HAVE A MOTION.
CENTER LEYVA HAS A MOTION TO OF
WHO THE BILL FORWARD TO DO
PASSED TO THE THE PAST TO AND AS
AMENDED TO THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE YES.
GLAZER I IS THERE I CHIANG.
ARCHULETA I PARTULA I'D DOT.
DODD AYE GALGIANI GALGIANI AYE
HILL BY HILL AYE LEYVA AYE LEYVA
AYE PAN I CAN I WILK ALL RIGHT
WILL NOT CENTER WINNER THAT HAS
ENOUGH BILLS THE VOTES TO GET
OUT THAT WE DO HAVE AN ABSENT
MEMBERS WILL HOLD THE ROLE OPEN.
THANK YOU FOR CALLING THANK YOU
MISTER EVERYBODY WAS HERE ON
THAT DEL ****.
WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON TO THE THE
NEXT BILL ON OUR AGENDA CENTER
SENATE BILL TWO OH ONE BY CENTER
WIENER SENATOR WELCOME AGAIN. TO
TO BEGAN AS YOU SEE FIT.
WE'RE GONNA GO BY THE SAME
GROUND RULES THAT WE'VE
ESTABLISHED HERE THERE WERE
LOSSES WERE STUCK IN A TRAFFIC
JAM NO PROBLEM.
TAKE A MOMENT [inaudible]
HISTORY CLOCK.
THANK YOU TO ALL OF THE
WITH HIM
.
YES CENTER WIENER WELCOME.
I THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
I WANT TO THANK YOU AND YOUR
STAFF FOR WORKING DILIGENTLY
WITH US.
ON ON THIS BILL -- AND I WANNA
KNOW US NOW SAID THE COMMITTEE
DID MENTION SOME TECHNICAL
AMENDMENTS AND ANALYSIS -- NOT
THE POLICY MA'AM SO THIRTY ONE
AND THEN SOME RAPID TO ACCEPT
THOSE TECHNICAL MEMONS.
MY COLLEAGUES US BILL TWO A ONE
IS A LONG OVERDUE -- PIECE OF
LEGISLATION -- TO ENSURE THAT
PEOPLE WHO ARE BORN INTERSEX ARE
ABLE TO MAKE THEIR OWN DECISIONS.
ABOUT THEIR OWN HEALTH AND THEIR
OWN GENDER IDENTITY AND THEIR
OWN BODIES.
RATHER THAN HAVING PERMANENT.
IRREVERSIBLE MEDICALLY
UNNECESSARY SURGERIES PERFORMED
ON WITHOUT THEM HAVING EVEN THE
SLIGHTEST ABILITY TO HAVE ANY
INPUT.
ON TO WHETHER TO HAVE THOSE
PERMANENT IRREVERSIBLE MEDICALLY
UNNECESSARY SURGERIES.
SURGERIES THAT MAY ASSIGN THEM A
GENDER THAT IS NOT THEIR ACTUAL
GENDER AND SURGERIES AND MAY
HAVE PERMANENT NEGATIVE
CONSEQUENCES FOR THEM LIFE. TO
BE CLEAR SB TWO OH ONE IS NOT
ABOUT REMOVING PARENTS WERE
PHYSICIANS FROM THE DECISION ON
WHETHER OR NOT TO HAVE SURGERY.
WHAT IT IS ABOUT IS ENSURING
THAT THE PERSON WHOSE BODY IS
BEING OPERATED ON?
IS ACTUALLY A PART OF THAT
DECISION.
BECAUSE THE BABY BY DEFINITION
CANNOT BE PART OF THAT DECISION
RIGHT NOW THE ONLY PERSON WHO IS
INVOLVED IS A PERSON WHOSE BODY
IS BEING PERMANENTLY CHANGE.
THE PERSON WHO'S GENERAL'S WILL
BE PERMANENTLY IN YOUR REVERSAL
CHANGE.
AND THE PERSON WHO MAY BE
PERMANENTLY STERILIZED.
MAY PERMANENTLY LOSE SEXUAL
SENSATION OR MAY HAVE PERMANENT
INCONTINENCE PROBLEMS THAT
PERSON SHOULD HAVE PARTICIPATION
AND A SAY.
IN THEIR FUTURE.
ALL WE'RE ASKING COLLEAGUES.
IS THAT THE PERSON WHO'S BEING
OPERATED ON BE ABLE TO WEIGH IN
IT'S NOT SIMPLE.
AND TO BE CLEAR.
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT MEDICALLY
UNNECESSARY SURGERIES.
SURGERIES THAT CAN BE SAFELY
DEFERRED THE BILL IS VERY CLEAR
THAT IF THE SURGERY IS MEDICALLY
NECESSARY FOR EXAMPLE IF A CHILD
CANNOT URINATE.
THAN THE SURGERY OF COURSE MAY
AND SHOULD BE PERFORMED.
ON THAT BABY.
SINCE THE NINETEEN FIFTIES AND
IT WASN'T ALWAYS THIS WAY.
SINCE THE NINETEEN FIFTIES.
MEDICAL PRACTICE IN MANY CASES
HAS BEEN TO PERFORM POTENTIALLY
DANGEROUS SEX ASSIGNMENT AND
QUOTE ON QUOTE NORMALIZATION ARE
SURGERY.
ON THE SEX CHARACTERISTICS OF
INTERSEX BABIES.
IN ORDER TO MAKE THEM APPEAR
QUOTE UNQUOTE NORMAL.
THERE IS NO COMPELLING EVIDENCE
TO SUGGEST THAT THESE VERY
PERSONAL DECISIONS NEED TO BE
MADE BY DOCTORS AND PARENTS SO
EARLY IN LIFE.
AND THERE IS A GREAT DEAL OF
RESEARCH INDICATING THE SUCH
PROCEDURES CAN HAVE DEVASTATING
LIFELONG CONSEQUENCES.
WE ARE CURRENTLY ALLOWING
DOCTORS AND PARENTS TO MAKE
THESE DECISIONS AND WE WANT THE
CHILDREN TO BE INVOLVED.
I WANT TO BE ALSO VERY CLEAR --
WE ARE LUCKY TO HAVE SOME OF THE
BEST.
DOCTORS IN THE WORLD HERE IN
CALIFORNIA.
I AM PARTICULARLY PROUD OF YOU
SEE US OUT IN MY DISTRICT.
THIS IS NOT ABOUT AN ATTACK ON
THE MEDICAL PROFESSION.
PHYSICIANS SAVE LIVES EVERY
SINGLE DAY IN OUR COMMUNITY.
I'M A BIG SUPPORTER OF THE
MEDICAL PROFESSION.
AND I HAVE ON MANY CASES MANY
SITUATIONS BEEN ALLIED TO THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
INCLUDING ON SOME VERY VERY
DIFFICULT ISSUES.
YOUR DOCTORS ARE NOT ALWAYS
RIGHT.
AND THE MEDICAL PROFESSION IS
NOT ALWAYS RIGHT.
IN FACT WITH THE LGBT COMMUNITY
AND SEXUAL MINORITIES THERE IS A
NOT SO PRETTY HISTORY.
SOME PHYSICIANS USED TO PERFORM
LOBOTOMIES ON LGBT CHILDREN. TO
QUOTE UNQUOTE FIX THEM AND MAKE
THEM QUOTE UNQUOTE NORMAL.
SOME PHYSICIANS USED TO PERFORM
ELECTRIC SHOCK THERAPY. ONE LGBT
PEOPLE TO QUOTE ON QUOTE FIX AND
NORMALIZE THEM.
POSITIONS IN CALIFORNIA SOME.
USED TO PERFORM CONVERSION
THERAPY ON OUR LGBT CHILDREN TO
FIX QUOTE UNQUOTE AND NORMALIZE
THEM BEFORE WE BANDED.
WITH BAND FEMALE GENITAL
MUTILATION AND STERILIZATION OF
MINORS FOR SIMILAR REASONS.
OVERWHELMINGLY WE SHOULD DEFER
TO PHYSICIANS MEDICAL JUDGMENTS.
ABOUT THEIR PATIENTS.
BUT NOT ALWAYS.
AND THERE ARE RARE AND
EXCEPTIONAL CIRCUMSTANCES.
WHERE MEDICAL PRACTICES CAN
VIOLATE OUR FUNDAMENTAL VALUES
AS A SOCIETY AND WE HAVE A
RESPONSIBILITY TO TAKE ACTION?
THE MEDICAL PROFESSION CONTRARY
TO WHAT.
HAS BEEN EXPRESSED.
IS NOT UNIFIED HERE.
AND I THINK IT'S VERY IMPORTANT
TO UNDERSTAND THAT MANY
PHYSICIANS TWO OF THEM ARE WITH
ME HERE TODAY.
STRONGLY DISAGREE WITH THE
POSITION.
THAT THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION AND OTHER
ASSOCIATIONS HAVE TAKEN.
ON THIS BILL AND ON THIS ISSUE --
BUT IT'S NOT JUST RANK AND FILE
PHYSICIANS WHO HOLD THIS VIEW.
IN SUPPORT OF SB TO A ONE INDEED
YOU ALL SHOULD RECEIVE A JOINT
STATEMENT FROM THREE FORMER US
SURGEON GENERAL.
ONE OF POINT IN BY GEORGE W.
BUSH TO APPOINTED BY BILL
CLINTON [inaudible]
CATEGORICALLY.
CATEGORICALLY REJECTING THE
SURGERIES.
QUOTE WHEN AN INDIVIDUAL IS BORN
AND I'M READING FROM THE
STATEMENT.
WHEN INDIVIDUAL IS BORN WITH A
TYPICAL GENITALIA THAT POSE NO
PHYSICAL RISK?
TREATMENT SHOULD FOCUS NOT ON
SURGICAL INTERVENTION BUT ON
CYCLE SOCIAL AND EDUCATIONAL
SUPPORT [inaudible]
QUOTE.
BECAUSE MEDIC JANITOR PLASTI
SHOULD BE DEFERRED UNTIL
CHILDREN ARE OLD ENOUGH TO VOICE
THEIR OWN VIEW.
ABOUT WHETHER TO UNDERGO THE
SURGERY.
QUOTE THOSE WHOSE OATH OR
CONSCIOUS SAY DO NO HARM SHOULD
HE THE SIMPLE FACT THAT TO DATE
RESEARCH DOES NOT SUPPORT THE
PRACTICE.
OF COSMETIC INFANT GENERAL
PLASTIC.
THESE ARE THREE FORMER SURGEON
GENERAL.
THE UNITED NATIONS REPORT ON
TORTURE.
STATES QUOTE CHILDREN WHO ARE
BORN WITH A TYPICAL SEX%
CHARACTERISTICS ARE OFTEN
SUBJECT TO YOUR REVERSIBLE
SEXIST SIMON.
INVOLUNTARY STERILIZATION
INVOLUNTARY GENITAL NORMALIZING
SURGERY.
PERFORMED WITHOUT THEIR INFORMED
CONSENT OR THAT OF THEIR PARENTS
IN AN ATTEMPT TO QUOTE FIX THEIR
SOCKS.
LEAVING THEM WITH PERMANENT
IRREVERSIBLE INFERTILITY AND
CAUSING SEVERE MEDICAL SUFFERING.
THE US STATE DEPARTMENT HAS MADE
A SIMILAR STATEMENT.
AMNESTY INTERNATIONAL HUMAN
RIGHTS WATCH GROUP SEPARATE TACT
HUMAN RIGHTS IN THIS WORLD.
HAVE TAKEN THE SAME POSITION.
COLLEAGUES.
I EXPRESSED TO THE OPPOSITION TO
THIS BILL EARLY ON MY DESIRE TO
WORK WITH THEM. TO TAKE FEEDBACK
WITH A BILL.
THAT WE CAN MOVE FORWARD.
THEY HAVE STEADFASTLY TOLD ME NO
THANK YOU.
WE'RE NOT INTERESTED IN WORKING
WITH YOU ARE NEGOTIATING WITH
YOU ON THIS BILL WE ARE SIMPLY
CATEGORICALLY OPPOSED.
THEY HAVE EVERY RIGHT OF COURSE
TO TAKE THAT POSITION AND I'M
NOT CRITICIZING THEM FOR
REFUSING TO NEGOTIATE WITH US.
BUT OUR ROLES LEGISLATORS
SOMETIMES IS TO FORCE THOSE
CONVERSATIONS.
AND BY VOTING THIS BILL OUT OF
COMMITTEE TODAY.
THAT WILL FORCE THIS LONG
OVERDUE CONVERSATION.
SO I ASK YOU TO ALLOW THAT
CONVERSATION TO PROCEED AND
AFTER THIS VERY VERY FIRST
COMMITTEE HEARING ON THIS BILL.
RATHER THAN.
SHUTTING IT OFF TODAY.
ALSO COLLEAGUES I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
A WITH ME TODAY OR KIMBERLY'S IS
SOMEONE WHO IS AN INTERSEX
PERSON AND THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF INTERACT --
ADVOCATES FOR INTERSEX YOUTH --
DOT DOCTOR I LEAN ONE GREGORIO --
A UROLOGIST A SURGEON AND A
BOARD MEMBER OF INTERACT.
WE'RE ALSO JOINED BY DOCTOR
SCOTT NASS WHO IS A FAMILY
PHYSICIAN FROM PALM SPRINGS AND
THE PRESIDENT ELECT OF GL IN MAY
WHICH WAS FORMALLY CALLED THE
GAY AND LESBIAN MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION.
AND WE'RE ALSO JOINED.
BY TOMMY MARTIN FROM A QUALITY --
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU VERY GOOD
THE CENTER WINNER THANK YOU FOR
YOUR OPENING ON THE BILL WELCOME
TO THE WITNESSES WE HAVE SIX
MINUTES COLLECTIVELY HELP YOU
GUYS ORGANIZE YOURSELF.
WE ARE LOOKING TO BEGIN ANYWAY
YOU WANT.
HI.
MY NAME IS KIMBERLY DIESEL MEN
AND I AM A LAWYER.
A PARENT AND THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF INTERACT ADVOCATES
FOR INTERSECTS YOU.
I'M ALSO AN INTERSEX WOMAN.
WHEN I WAS GROWING UP INTERSEX
TRAITS WERE KEPT SECRET AT ALL
COSTS?
I LEARN THE TRUTH ABOUT MY BODY
AT AGE.
FORTY ONE AFTER DOCTORS LIED TO
ME AND MY FAMILY FOR DECADES.
WHILE ADMITTEDLY SOME THINGS
HAVE CHANGED FOR KIDS LIKE ME.
MANY THINGS HAVEN'T.
BODIES LIKE MINE HAVE EXISTED
THROUGHOUT HISTORY WITHOUT ANY
NEED FOR SURGERY.
IT WAS A FEAR OF GAY AND
TRANSGENDER PEOPLE THAT LED TO
THE FIRST INTERVENTIONS ON A
TYPICAL GENITALIA.
WOMEN WITH LARGE **** IS WHERE
PRIMARY CONCERN. FOR FEAR THAT
THEY WOULD PURSUE LESBIAN
RELATIONSHIPS.
IT'S IMPOSSIBLE TO TALK ABOUT
WHERE WE ARE TODAY WITHOUT
UNDERSTANDING THIS PRACTICES
HISTORICAL ROOTS.
IN SEXISM AND HOMOPHOBIA.
JUST AS LGBT PEOPLE FOUGHT
AGAINST BEING CLASSIFIED AS
MENTAL DISORDERS.
INTERSEX PEOPLE PEOPLE FIGHT
AGAINST BEING CLASSIFIED AS
PHYSICAL DISORDERS.
I AM HERE ON BEHALF OF OUR YOUNG
PEOPLE.
WHO HAVE ATTEMPTED SUICIDE?
WHEN THEY LEARNED THEIR SEXUAL
DYSFUNCTION WHAT'S CAUSED BY
INFANT HYPOSPADIAS SURGERY?
I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF OUR YOUTH
WHO HAVE LOST SEXUAL SENSATION
TO INFANT CLITORAL REDUCTIONS.
AND OUR YOUNG PEOPLE WHO WEAR
DIAPERS FOR INCONTINENCE BECAUSE
OF INFANT.
VAGINOPLASTY IS.
FRANKLY WHAT HURTS THE MOST IS
NOT THE PHYSICAL PAIN BUT THE
KNOWLEDGE THAT WE WERE ROBBED OF
OUR OWN MOST INTIMATE CHOICES.
IF OPPONENTS CLAIM THIS IS NO
LONGER HAPPENING.
IT'S BECAUSE THEIR OWN
DEFINITION OF INTERSEX IS
INTENTIONALLY NARROW.
A RECENT PUBLIC RECORDS ACT
REQUEST BY INTERACTIONS THAT
OVER FOUR THOUSAND SUCH
SURGERIES WERE REIMBURSED BY
MEDICARE ALL IN THE LAST THREE
YEARS.
WITH PROCEDURES TO RELOCATE IN
ALREADY FUNCTIONAL URETHRA.
AND TO CREATE OR ALTER OF THE
JOURNAL OPENING AMONG THE MOST
COMMON.
WELL NOT EVERYONE USES THE TERM
INTERSECTS FOR MYSELF AND FOR
MANY OTHERS INCLUDING THE YOUTH
THAT I OVERSEE.
IT HAS BECOME A GUIDING LIGHT A
RECLAMATION THAT OUR BODIES OUR
OWN.
THE WORLD HAS HELPED THE WORD
HAS HELPED US HEAL FROM MEDICAL
TRAUMA.
AND UNDERSTAND THAT WE ARE NOT
BROKEN.
REGARDLESS OF TERMINOLOGY
CHILDREN WITH VARIATIONS OF
THEIR SEX STRAITS.
DESERVES TO BE CENTERED.
IN THIS IRREVERSIBLE DECISION
ABOUT THEIR OWN BODY THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS EILEEN LONG I'M A
STAND FOR TRAINED UROLOGIST AND
I'M HERE BECAUSE I TRULY BELIEVE
THAT INTERSECTS CARE I ONE OF
THE GREATEST ETHICAL FAILURES OF
MODERN MEDICINE.
CALIFORNIA LAW ALREADY PROTECTS
MINORS FROM THE HARMS OF
CONVERSION THERAPY STERILIZATION
AND FEMALE GENITAL MUTILATION
BUT MOST MODIFICATIONS TO
NORMALIZE INTERSECTS ANATOMY ARE
SOMEHOW STILL CONDONED DESPITE
SIMILAR RISKS.
DATA SUPPORTING THESE PROCEDURES
IS NOTORIOUSLY POOR QUALITY IN
CENTERS PARENTAL PERCEPION IN
COSMETIC OUTCOMES NOT PATIENT
EXPERIMENTSEXPERIENCE AND
FUNCTION.
THESE FIRST FOUR PROCEDURES ARE
ALL PERFORMED ON THE IASED AN
UNPROVEN ASSUMPTION THAT MEETING
SOCIAL GENDER NORMS WILL JUSTIFY
INTENSE MEDICAL RISKS FOR ALL
PATIENTS.
MANY CHILDREN HAVE GROWN UP WITH
DECREASE IN STATION OR NORGAY
ORGASMIC FUNCTION AND A MAJORITY
OF INFANT VAGINOPLASTY IS
REQUIRED INVASIVE FOLLOW UP
SURGERIES.
THESE FEMINIZING PROCEDURES ARE
MOST COMMONLY DONE IN PATIENTS
WITH CONGENITAL ADRENAL
HYPERPLASIA ONE OF THE MOST
COMMON CAUSES OF NATIONAL
GENERAL DIFFERENCE YET DATA
SHOWED THAT UP TO ONE EIGHTH OF
THESE PATIENTS DO NOT IDENTIFY
AS FEMALE.
MY DUTY AS A PHYSICIAN IS TO DO
NO HARM TO MY PATIENTS.
WHEN THE FDA ISSUED A WARNING
ABOUT A VAGINAL MESS PRODUCT
AFTER ONLY 5210% OF PATIENTS
COMPLAIN I ADJUSTED MY PRACTICE?
BY COMPARISON DISSATISFACTION
RATES FOR SOME PROCEDURES SB TWO
ONE COVERS ARE CITED AS 4250%.
IF INTEREST TAX SURGERY WERE
MEDICAL DEVICE THE FDA WOULD
NEVER HAVE APPROVED IT.
CERTAINLY THERE ARE SOME ADULTS
WHO ARE SATISFIED THAT THESE
CHOICES WERE MADE FROM THEM BUT
THE RISKS ARE TOO HIGH TO GAS
WHICH BABIES WILL BE WHICH MANY
OF THE ADULTS HARM BY THESE
INTERVENTIONS FIND IT ALMOST
IMPOSSIBLE. TO FIND DOCTORS TO
CARE FOR THEM AFTER THE EIGHT
OUT OF PEDIATRICS AND I HAVE TO
SAY IN MY EXPERIENCE THIS IS
MEDICAL ABANDONMENT.
WHAT MULTI DISCIPLINARY
TREATMENT TEAMS DO EXIST THEY
ARE STILL RARE AND LACKED THE
MOST IMPORTANT DECISION MAKER?
THE PATIENT.
THE ONLY WAY TO DO NO HARM IS TO
WAIT AND LET THOSE WHO MAY WANT
SURGERIES TO PERSONALLY WAY IN.
WHAT THEY'RE WILLING TO TOLERATE?
AS MANY INTERSECTS AND
TRANSGENDER CHILDREN SO WEST
GENITALIA CHROMOSOMES CANNOT
RELIABLY INDICATE HOW CHILD
IDENTIFY THEIR GENDER OR WHAT
SURGERIES THEY MAY OR MAY NOT
WANT.
SB TO A ONE WILL STILL A WORK IN
PROGRESS REGARDING ITS SCOPE
CENTERS INDIVIDUAL CONSENT AND
PRESERVES OPTIONS FOR CHILDREN
THE PATIENTS WE ARE TREATING.
I AM PROUD TO SUPPORT THIS BILL
MEANT -- TO HAVE FLOWN FROM
PHILADELPHIA AND AND WOULD BE
TAKING A RED EYE HOME TOMORROW
AN OPERATING FULL DAY.
BECAUSE WE DON'T NEED TO CHANGE
INTERSEX BODIES WE NEED TO
CHANGE OUR PRACTICE.
THANK YOU TAMMY MARTIN WITH
EQUALITY CALIFORNIA SPONSOR OF
SB TO A ONE WHICH AT ITS CORE IS
ABOUT THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
RESPECTING AN INDIVIDUAL'S
AUTONOMY OVER THEIR OWN BODY.
AND IN SOME CASES GENDER
IDENTITY WHICH IS FUNDAMENTAL TO
ALL THE WORK THATWE DO ON LGBT
Q. RIGHTS.
AND IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE
CONTINUE TO EXHIBIT CALIFORNIA
LEADERSHIP BECAUSE THE SITUATION
TODAY IS NOT MEDICALLY
UNNECESSARY SURGERIES THAT CAUSE
LONG LASTING AND PERMANENT HARM
ARE BEING PERFORMED ON CHILDREN
WITHOUT THEIR INVOLVEMENT OR
CONSENT.
WHICH IS A HUMAN RIGHTS
VIOLATION.
AND THAT'S WHY WE STAND WITH
SENATOR WIENER AND SPONSORING
THE THIS BILL AND URGE THE
COMMITTEE TO SUPPORT AS WELL.
HELLO I'M SCOTT NASA I'M A
FAMILY PHYSICIAN IN PALM SPRINGS
CALIFORNIA AND I PARTNER WITH A
GENERAL VERSE PATIENTS ACROSS
THE LIFESPAN FROM YOUTH TO
ADULTS.
AND I'M HERE TODAY IN MY ROLE AS
PRESIDENT ELECT OBAMA HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS ADVANCING LGBT Q.
A QUALITY FORMERLY KNOWN AS THE
GAY LESBIAN MEDICAL ASSOCIATION.
AND I'M REPRESENTING OUR MEMBERS
AND OTHER INTERESTED PARTIES WHO
SUPPORT STRONG SCIENCE BASE
POLICY WHICH WE PUBLISHED A
COUPLE OF YEARS AGO I'M
ADVOCATING FOR DEFERRED
SURGERIES ON INTERSEX CHILDREN.
ASWELL AS THE EIGHTY TWO
INDIVIDUALS WHO SIGNED A RECENT --
SIGN ON SUPPORT LETTER FOR TESTS
ARE SENATE BILL TWO A ONE I'M
HERE TO SHARE THAT WE DO BELIEVE
THIS IS AN LGBT Q. ISSUE THIS IS
WHEN WE'RE HAPPY TO ADVOCATE.
OF ON BEHALF OF THE INDIVIDUALS
WHO'VE COME FORWARD AS PATIENTS
AND ASKED US TO BE INVOLVED.
AND I'M HERE TO AS A PHYSICIAN
CENTER THE ROLE CENTER THE
VOICES OF THOSE WITH THE LIVED
EXPERIENCE SOMETHING I CAN'T
POSSIBLY TALK ABOUT MYSELF THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AT CENTER
WINNER IN ALL YOUR WITNESSES.
TERMS OF TRYING TO FIND BALANCE
AND FAIRNESS TO ONE A LITTLE
OVER BUT WE'LL TRY TO BALANCE IT
OUT -- WHEN WHEN THE OPPOSITION
COMES UP I'D LIKE TO INVITE --
ANYONE WHO IS ALSO IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL TO COME UP TO THE
MICROPHONE.
AND AGAIN NOT.
UNDER A COMMITTEE -- RULES WOULD
LIKE TO JUST ASK THAT YOU GIVE
YOUR NAME AND AFFILIATION IF YOU
DO HAVE -- ONE AND YOUR
INDICATION THAT A POSITION ON
THE BILL AND AND FORTUNATELY WE
DON'T HAVE TIME FOR TOO MUCH
ELSE SO WELCOME AND GO AHEAD.
KRAMER MATTER ON BEHALF OF THE
ACLU OF CALIFORNIA PROUD
SPONSORS OF THE SPELL THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU PANEL MEMBERS OF MY
NAME IS AT THE JOHNSON I DROVE
ACROSS BACK TODAY I MEAN
AFFECTED INTERSEX PERSON.
AND I'M AN INDEPENDENT ADVOCATE
ASSOCIATED WITH INTERACT.
ADVOCATES FOR YOUTH I SUPPORT
THE BILL AND I THANK YOU FOR
YOUR SUPPORT OF IT AS WELL.
THANK YOU COMMITTEE MEMBERS ARE
I AM A COMMUNITY MEMBER FROM
SOME MOST BY FROM THE LA IF FROM
THE SAN FERNANDO VALLEY SHOWING
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ARNOLD ALLERGY GRAY
FROM SAN FRANCISCO I'M AN
INDEPENDENT ARTIST AN ADVOCATE
WRITER AND STRONG SUPPORT AND
I'M ALSO.
QUEER WHICH I THINK [inaudible]
ISRAEL.
HEY I'M HANS I MEAN INTERSEX
PERSON I ALSO SERVED AS
COMMUNICATIONS DIRECTOR WITH
INTERACT IN SUPPORT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HELLO I'M PIXIE PEARL FROM THE
SACRAMENTO LGBT COMMUNITY CENTER
AND I'M ALSO AND INTERSECTS
ADULT LIVING WITH NEGATIVE
EFFECTS FROM THIS NON CONSENSUAL
SURGERY.
SO I'M STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
YOUR DRY ON THE BOARD OF THE
SACRAMENTO LGBT COMMUNITY CENTER.
THANK YOU. FOR MY NAME IS MUDDY
ROAD VIA I AM A INTERSEX PERSON
LIVING IN SACRAMENTO AND I
SUPPORT.
MY NAME SAID ABOUT I'M A CO
FOUNDER OF SAN OF EVERY
TRANSGENDER ADVOCACY NETWORK AND
I FACILITATE A TRANS YOUTH.
A SUPPORT GROUP EVERY WEEK AND I
AM IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
VERY GOOD THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ANYBODY ELSE -- WHEN I COME
FORWARD TO INDICATE SUPPORT FOR
THIS?
LEGISLATION ALL RIGHT SEE.
NINE THANK THE WITNESSES AT THE
TABLE AND INVITE THOSE WHO ARE
IN OPPOSITION -- TO COME UP
LEAVE THEM ORGANIZE THEMSELVES.
AT THE END [inaudible]
YEAH YEAH.
ALL RIGHT SO I HAVE ONE INVITE
THE WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION --
TO IDENTIFY THEMSELVES WE DID
HAVE A CLOCK RUNNING SO IT'S
ABOUT -- WONDER SEVEN MINUTES
FOR YOU COLLECTIVELY AND WE
WELCOME YOU AND PLEASE PROCEED
THANK YOU -- I DR KELLY SORTS OF
A PEDIATRIC UROLOGIST FROM RATED
CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL IN SAN DIEGO.
ADRIAN MARKS I HAVE CONGENITAL
ADRENAL HYPERPLASIA AND I HAD
GENITAL SURGERY AT A EARLY AGE
AND ALSO A MEMBER OF THE LGBT
PLUS COMMUNITY.
THE PEDIATRIC ENDOCRINOLOGIST
PRACTICING AT UC DAVIS AND I'M
HERE IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL AS
WELL.
AUTHORED ANSWER COULD AFTERNOON
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK -- THIS LITTLE BIT ABOUT
MY BACKGROUND AS A FELLOW I
HELPED CREATE -- THE DIFFERENCES
AND SEXUAL DIFFERENTIATION --
CLINIC AT THE MULTI DISCIPLINARY
CLINIC AT MY INSTITUTION AND I
PRACTICE AT RADIO AND WE HAVE
THIS IS VERY SIMILAR MULTI
DISCIPLINARY CLINIC -- ON BEHALF
OF MYSELF YOUR LOGIC COMMUNITY
THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION AND SPECIALIST TO
TREAT THESE PATIENTS WE'RE IN
STRONG OPPOSITION TO SB TO A ONE
WELL MY TITLE MIGHT BE PEDIATRIC
UROLOGIST I AM FIRST AND
FOREMOST.
A PATIENT ADVOCATE EVERY SINGLE
DAY.
THIS INCLUDES MAKING
INDIVIDUALIZED RECOMMENDATIONS
FOR EACH PATIENT BY EDUCATING
FAMILIES SO THEY CAN ACT IN
THEIR CHILDREN'S BEST INTERESTS.
I FIRMLY BELIEVE THAT HEALTHCARE
IS NOT ONE SIZE FITS ALL EACH
PERSON I INTERACT WITH DESERVES
YOU NEED CARE THIS CRAFTED
SPECIFICALLY FOR THEM.
SB TWO OH ONE JUST DOES JUST THE
OPPOSITE AND TREATS EVERY CHILD
THE SAME IGNORING THE IMPACT OF
DELAYED TREATMENT.
IS IMPORTANT TO SAY THAT I'M
VERY GRATEFUL THAT WE HAVE
LAWMAKERS WHO ARE AIMING TO
PROTECT CHILDREN.
AND UNITED WITH YOU IN THIS
ENDEAVOR.
SB TWO ONE IT'S BROAD DEFINITION
OF INTERSEX THAT THE MEDICAL
COMMUNITY AT LARGE DOES NOT
SUPPORT THE UNPRECEDENTED
DEFINITION OF INFORMED CONSENT
THAT IS UNWORKABLE.
AND VISITED LEFT THE PROVISIONS
THAT HINDER A MEDICAL
PROFESSIONALS ABILITY TO
RECOMMEND CARES ALARMING.
THE BILL RESULT IN CHILDREN BE
EXPOSED TO MORE PHYSICAL AND
EMOTIONAL PAIN AND IN THE LONG
RUN LIKELY RESULT IN INCREASED
NUMBER OF SURGERIES NEEDED. FOR
EXAMPLE HYPERSPACE THE HYPE IS
BDS IS COMMON IT OCCURSIN
APPROXIMATELY ONE IN TWO HUNDRED
AND FIFTY BOYS IT IS NOT AN
INTERSEX CONDITION.
IN SIMPLE TERMS TYPE THE
SPEEDIEST IS WHEN THE WHOLE THAT
AVOID PIECE FROM IS NOT ON THE
TIP OF THE **** BUT LOWER ON THE
SHAFT.
THE H. ALSO ON THE BILL IS ALSO
NOT AN INTERSEX CONDITION.
THESE PATIENTS ARE GENETICALLY
MALE AND FEMALE AND DO NOT
CONSIDER THEMSELVES -- SEX.
LAST MONTH I VOLUNTEERED N
GHANA THE TEACHING PERFORM
HYPOSPADIAS SURGERY.
THERE NO PEDIATRIC UROLOGIST IN
WESTERN AFRICA WEST AFRICA THEIR
FOUR CHILDREN FAMILIES AND THEIR
DOCTORS TRAVEL FROM FAR TO COME
AND SEE OF CS.
MANY HAVE BEEN WAITING FOR YEARS
FOR THEIR SURGERY.
MOST WERE MUCH OLDER THAN THE
AVERAGE SIX TO TWELVE MONTHS OF
AGE THAT WE PERFORM SURGERIES ON
IN THE UNITED STATES.
I GOT TO SEE THEIR INCREASED
PAIN POPS DISHES WITH ERECTIONS
AND EXTREME DISCOMFORT WITH
CATHETERS FIRST HAND DESPITE
THIS THESE YOUNG MEN REMAIN
THANKFUL THAT THEY WOULD FINALLY
BE ABLE TO HAVE STRAIGHT OR
ACTIONS AND PEE STANDING UP.
AND NOW I CONTINUE TO KEEP IN
TOUCH WITH THE GUARDIAN
UROLOGIST THESE OLDER BOYS ARE
HEALING MORE POORLY.
THAN THEIR YOUNGER COUNTERPARTS
IN A LARGER NUMBER WILL NEED A
SECOND SURGERY TO FULLY CORRECT
THEIR HIVE SPEEDIEST SURGERY.
SB TWO OH ONE PUTS CALIFORNIA
BOYS AT RISK THE SAME
COMPLICATIONS.
FRIEDMAN OF DST HAS CHANGED
ADVANCE SIGNIFICANTLY IN THE
LAST TWENTY YEARS.
IT IS UNFORTUNATE THAT MANY OF
THE SUPPORTERS OF THIS BILL SITE
CASES FROM THIRTY PLUS YEARS AGO
AS JUSTIFICATION TO PASS THIS
BILL.
I SYMPATHIZE DEEPLY WITH THESE
PATIENTS THAT WERE TREATED IN
THIS ERA.
HOWEVER WE NOW TAKE A TEAM CARE
APPROACH THE PROVIDES FAMILIES
RESOURCES AND CHOICES.
AND MANY CASES SURGERY IS NOT
OFFERED IT IS IMPORTANT TO HAVE
OPTIONS THE S. B. TWO OH ONE
REMOVES.
I WOULD LIKE TO MAKE AN
IMPORTANT POINT IN TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN THE AMERICAN MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION SPENT ONE AND A HALF
YEARS INDEPENDENTLY REVIEWING
ALL THE DATA FROM BOTH SIDES
RELATED TO DST.
AND THE ESTABLISHED THE COULD
NOT SUPPORT A MORATORIUM ON
GENERAL SURGERY FOR PATIENTS
WITH THE SD. TWO YEARS LATER IN
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN ELEVEN
PROFESSIONAL ORGANIZATIONS THAT
RANGE FROM PSYCHIATRY ENTER
CANNELLA G. STATURE THINKON
ECOLOGY UROLOGY AND HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS ADVANCING LGBT
EQUALITY REVIEW THE DATA AS WELL
AND JOINED IN SUPPORTING THE AMA
ITS POSITION.
WELL I UNDERSTAND THE SENATOR'S
INTENT WITHHOLDING TREATMENT
OPTIONS AND TREATING CHILDREN AS
IF THEY'RE ONE SIZE FITS ALL
WILL NEGATIVELY AFFECT THESE
PATIENTS PHYSICAL AND
PSYCHOLOGICAL HEALTH.
SENATE BILL TO A ONE IS THE
WRONG APPROACH AND RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOU TO VOTE NO.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR TIME
AND ATTENTION.
THANK YOU CHAIRMAN GLAZER AND
FELLOW COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
MY NAME IS ADRIAN MARKS I AM A
TWENTY SEVEN YEAR OLD NURSE
PRACTITIONER FROM NAPA
CALIFORNIA.
AND I'M HERE TODAY AS A MEMBER
OF THE LGBT PLUS COMMUNITY AND
AS AN INDIVIDUAL WHO HAD GENITAL
SURGERY AT A YOUNG AGE.
SPEAKING IN OPPOSITION SENATE
BILL TO A ONE WITHIN THE FIRST
TWENTY FOUR HOURS OF BEING BORN
I WAS TRANSFERRED TO INTENSIVE
CARE.
MY PARENTS SOON LEARNED I WAS
BORN WITH A RARE ADRENAL GLAND
CONDITION CALLED CONGENITAL
ADRENAL HYPERPLASIA OR C. H..
IN THOSE FIRST FEW DAYS MY BODY
STRUGGLE TO SURVIVE.
AND IT WAS KNOWN MY LIFE WOULD
NOT BE EASY.
NOT ONLY WHAT I HAVE TO TAKE
MEDICATION THREE TIMES A DAY FOR
THE REST OF MY LIFE TO LIVE.
I WAS ALL I WOULD ALSO FACE THE
CHALLENGES OF BEING BORN WITH
GENITALIA THAT WAS NOT
FUNCTIONAL.
DUE TO C. H. I WAS EXPOSED TO AN
EXCESS AMOUNT OF MALE HORMONES
WHILE IN THE WOMB.
AS A GENETICALLY BORN FEMALE
THIS BECAUSE MY VAGINAL CANAL TO
FUSE EXTERNALLY AND CONNECTS
WITH MY URINARY TRACT.
I HAD GENERAL SURGERY AT THE
AGES OF ONE AND FOR TO OPEN MY
VAGINAL CANAL AND REPOSITION MY
****. TO BE CLEAR IN NO WAY WAS
MY **** CHOPPED OFF OR CUT.
AND TODAY I DO HAVE A HEALTHY
SEX LIFE.
SURGERY WAS NOT INTENDED TO MAKE
ME HETEROSEXUAL OR CHANGE MY
GENDER.
INSTEAD SURGERY REDUCE NUMEROUS
URINARY TRACT INFECTIONS AND
PREVENTED ME FROM STARTING MY
PERIOD THROUGH A SMALL URINARY
OPENING.
WHICH WOULD HAVE LEFT ME IN PAIN
AND TREMENDOUS EMOTIONAL
DISTRESS.
SB TWO OH ONE IS AMBIGUOUS AND
ITS LANGUAGE REGARDING MEDICAL
NECESSITY AND AGE OF CONSENT.
FOR EXAMPLE IF IT WAS IN PLACE
WHEN I WAS BORN.
THE ADVICE OF MY DOCTORS WOULD
HAVE BEEN SILENCED.
I WOULD HAVE BEEN FORCED TO
START KINDERGARTEN KNOWING I
WOULD WET MY PANTS AT SCHOOL
BECAUSE I COULD NOT CONTROL WHEN
TRAPPED YOUR AND PULLING IN MY
**** MIGHT COME OUT.
ACCORDING TO SB TWO OH ONE MY
SURGERIES WHAT HAVE BEEN DEEMED
MEDICALLY UNNECESSARY BECAUSE
WEDDING MYSELF UNCONTROLLABLY IS
NOT DISABLING OR CAUSING SEVERE
PAIN.
AND IT WOULD NOT RECOGNIZE MY
OWN PERSONAL TRAUMA BECAUSE THIS
BILL STATES PSYCHOLOGICAL
FACTORS DO NOT CONSTITUTE
MEDICAL NECESSITY.
I DO WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE THE
STORIES OF HARDSHIP AND PAIN OF
THE TRUE INTERSEX PEOPLE
EVERYONE SHOULD HEAR THEIR VOICE.
YES SB TWO OH ONE WAS ORGANIZED
WITHOUT HEARING THE VOICE OF THE
C. H. COMMUNITY.
I HAVE PERSONALLY SPOKEN TO C.
H. WOMEN WHO HAD SURGERY EARLY
AND SOME WHO HAD SURGERY LATE.
BOTH SIDES TOLD ME THEY DO NOT
WANT THIS BILL.
I AM NOT A SURGERY ADVOCATE BUT
I BELIEVE THIS BILL IS THE WRONG
ANSWER TO A VERY COMPLEX MATTER.
I BELIEVE BUNCHING OVER THIRTY
DIFFERENT CONDITIONS WHEN
THEY'RE ALL DISTINCTLY DIFFERENT
AND EACH PERSON IS UNIQUE IS
CARELESS.
PERCY H. THERE MAY NEVER BE A
PERFECT ANSWER BECAUSE IT IS A
HEART CONDITION TO LIVE WITH.
BUT I KNOW SENATE BILL TWO OH
ONE WOULD HAVE CREATED
ADDITIONAL HARDSHIPS FOR ME AND
MY FAMILY.
I KNOW A BILL THAT BLOCKS ACCESS
TO HEALTH CARE.
ASSUMES EVERY PERSONIS THE SAME
AND DISCREDITS MENTAL HEALTH.
WOULD HAVE MADE MY LIFE WORSE.
PLEASE VOTE NO ON SENATE BILL TO
A ONE THANK YOU ADRIN THANKS FOR
SHARING YOUR STORY.
WE HAVE EXCEEDED THE TIME THAT'S
BEEN A LOT IT IF THERE'S A QUICK
SUMMARY THAT YOU LIKE TO MAKE IT
YOUR TESTIMONY OR OR YOUR
CREDENTIALS AND AND MEMBERS MAY
HAVE QUESTIONS SURE -- I THINK
THAT'S MY RICK MINERAL ANYWAY
I'M A PEDIATRIC ENDOCRINOLOGIST
AT UC DAVIS AND I'D LIKE TO BE
HERE JUST ANSWER ANY COME HOME
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE ABOUT THE
VERY COMPLICATED BIOLOGY.
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT I'D LIKE TO
OFFER THE OPPORTUNITY FOR
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION TO COME
UP TO THE MICROPHONE.
AND IT.
IDENTIFY THEMSELVES IN ANY
ORGANIZATIONAL AFFILIATION IF
THEY WISH.
ADD AN INDICATION OF THEIR
POSITION ON THE BILL.
SO PLEASE COME FORWARD.
I MADE EARNS MOTHER I OPPOSE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
I'M PETER MARK SOME NAPA
CALIFORNIA I OPPOSE THIS BILL AS
A FATHER OF ADRIAN.
WHO HAS A CONGENITAL ADRENAL
HYPERPLASIA NOT IN INTERSECT
CONDITION THANK YOU?
HELLO.
THANK YOU ALL FOR OVERTIME MY
NAME'S NICOLE I VOTE IN.
A DISTRICT ELEVEN I'M A SEPARATE
SYSTEM -- IN I AM ALSO LGBT Q.
ADRIAN'S PARTNER -- AND I'M ALSO
A DOCTORAL CANDIDATE CLINICAL
PSYCH SO.
GIVING HERE.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
CHRIS I AM A PROUD MEMBER OF THE
TRANSGENDER COMMUNITY AND I
OPPOSE SB TWO ONE THANK YOU.
YOU.
HELLO MEMBERS MAP BACK
REPRESENTING THE SOCIETY TO
PEDIATRIC UROLOGY IN OPPOSITION
AND ALSO THE OSTEOPATHIC
PHYSICIANS AND SURGEONS OF
CALIFORNIA IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU.
MORNING MR MEMBERS BRANDON
MARCHING WITH THE CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION WE ARE
OPPOSED TO THE BILL AND ALIGN
OUR COMMENTS WITH DOCTORS
TOWARDS.
HELLO MY NAME IS JENNIFER YANG
I'M AN ASSOCIATE PROFESSOR OF
PEDIATRICS IN UROLOGY AT UC
DAVIS AND AYE OPPOSED TO SPELL.
THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS A KILLER -- I
AND AND MEMBER OF THE LGBT PLUS
COMMUNITY AND A QUARTER TO FIVE
FAMILY NURSE PRACTITIONER AYE
AYE OPPOSED THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS AMY LEE -- I AM
FROM THE SANTA BARBARA
CALIFORNIA DISTRICT -- NINETEEN
AND I YOU KNOW STRONGLY OPPOSES
BILL BECAUSE I DO HAVE A FRIEND
WHO HAS CH -- AND I URGE YOU
GUYS TO YOU -- VOTE NO ON THIS
AS WELL THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR
BEING HERE.
SCOTT SPARK SOME A PEDIATRIC
NEUROLOGIST AT CHILDREN'S
HOSPITAL LOS ANGELES.
AND AS A MEMBER OF THE LGBT
COMMUNITY ALSO OPPOSE THIS BILL
[inaudible]
HE OCCURS ROCK ON THE PROFESSOR
OF UROLOGY AND PEDIATRICS AT UC
DAVIS CHILDREN'S AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
RANDALL HAGER REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA PSYCHIATRIC
ASSOCIATION WE OPPOSE THIS BILL.
I AM DOCTOR PARKER CRASKE
PEDIATRIC UROLOGISTS FROM THE
CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL LOS ANGELES
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
RIGHT SPENCER ON BEHALF OF THE
AMERICAN CULTURE OBGYN STATURE
NINE IN OPPOSITION.
DR SECURE RODRIGUEZ PEDIATRIC
UROLOGISTS MEDICAL DIRECTOR
BALLOT CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL
MADERA CALIFORNIA I OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
IN A WAY WE COR A RESIDENT OF
SANTA CRUZ CALIFORNIA PARENT OF
A CHILD WITHOUT WASTING CH AND I
OPPOSE HE SPELL.
COURTNEY BAKER RESIDENT OF
SACRAMENTO COUNTY I'M A MOTHER
OF A DAUGHTER WITH SIMPLE
PARTISAN SEE EIGHT C. H. I.
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MICHELLE BISHOP YOUR G. FORTRESS
HOSPITAL THE MELINDA HELP WITH
HIS BILL.
HI STEPHANIE REPRESENTING
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA IRVINE
AND CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL OF
ORANGE COUNTY AND THE PEDIATRIC
UROLOGIST I OPPOSE THIS BILL
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
NANCY JOHNSON RESIDENT OF
FAIRFIELD CALIFORNIA AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
RANDY OLSON FOR OF RESIN
SACRAMENTO I'M A PROUD
GRANDFATHER OF A GRANDDAUGHTER
THAT HAS THE AGE AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL. TO MADDEN REPRESENT
CALIFORNIA'S SOCIETY PLASTIC
SURGEONS IN OPPOSITION.
MY NAME IS ERIC BROWN FROM LOS
ANGELES I A CH IS NOT INTERSEX
CONDITION IS MISLEADING TO
INCLUDE IN THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS THERESA ELLIS AND
I'M HERE FROM SACRAMENTO -- MY
SON JUST HAD HYPOSPADIAS SURGERY
AT THE BILL CLEAN BILL OF HEALTH
SO I'M HERE TO OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
BY.
CHELATING ON BEHALF OF THE
CHILDREN SPECIALTY CARE
COALITION AND OPPOSITION.
MY NAME IS KAREN BOGARD I'M FROM
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
I HAVE A CHILD WITH CH I'M ALSO
THE BOARD CHAIR OF CARES
FOUNDATION.
DONATIONS STRONGLY OPPOSES AS DO
I THE ORGANIZATION WORKS IN
CONJUNCTION WITH PHYSICIANS AND
SURGEONS AND HAS A PETITION IT'S
ONLY A YEAR OLD.
A WHAT YEAR OLD A WEEK LD WITH
ELEVEN HUNDRED SIGNATURES
OPPOSING THE BILL.
VERY MUCH ARE THERE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
ALL RIGHT SEEN ON WILL BRING THE
MATTER BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
THAT WE JUST FIRST THANK ALL THE
WITNESSES WHO OF COMMON.
IN FAVOR AND AGAINST A SHARE
THEIR THOUGHTS WITH US ON A VERY.
VERY DIFFICULT TOPIC AS I THINK
ALL OF US WHO HAVE LOOKED INTO
IT.
HAVE COME TO UNDERSTAND -- I
WANT TO BRING THE ISSUE BACK --
TO MY COMMITTEE.
MANY QUESTIONS THAT THAT THEY
MAY HAVE.
HAVE QUESTIONS FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS WE ARE READY LIKE TODAY
HI MISTER CHAIRMAN FIRST OF ALL --
I I DO WANT TO RECOGNIZE ALL THE
WITNESSES FOR BEING HERE TODAY
AND TELLING THEIR PERSONAL
STORIES ON BOTH SIDES I THINK
THAT -- YEAH VERY IMPORTANT.
TO YOU KNOW TO DO HERE I ALSO
WOULD LIKE -- TO JUST TAKE A
LITTLE BIT EXCEPTION WAS SENATOR
WINNERS COMMENTS AT ALL THE
OPPOSITION DIDN'T WANT TO
NEGOTIATE OR DO ANYTHING I'VE.
MADE IT CLEAR TO THE BILL'S
SPONSOR THAT I THOUGHT EDUCATION.
WAS SOMETHING PROVIDING -- TO TO
THE PARENTS -- INFORMATION --
FROM EQUALITY CALIFORNIA -- IT
FOR EVERY SINGLE PATIENT -- THAT
THAT MAY HAVE THIS CONDITION
BECAUSE I THINK EDUCATION IS
KNOWLEDGE IN PARTICULAR IT'S THE
CALIFORNIA THANK.
AS WE'VE KNOWN THAT PEOPLE ARE --
ARE ARE MORE OPEN EVERY SINGLE
DAY AND I THINK BILL.
WILL DO THE RIGHT THING BASED ON
BLB AN EDUCATED AND YEAH WHY DO
HAVE GREAT RESPECT FOR CENTER
WIENER AND ALSO EQUALITY
CALIFORNIA.
IN ALL ALL CONTINUE TO LISTEN AS
I'M SITTING HERE TODAY BUT
TAKING -- THAT SITUATION WHERE
YOU KNOW I HAVE. NINE GRANDKIDS
AND I JUST.
JUST CAN'T UNDERSTAND WHY WE
HAVE A SITUATION WHERE WE WOULD
TAKE AWAY THE ABILITY.
OF TWO ADULTS THAT ARE OPEN
MINDED. TO BE EDUCATED -- IT'S A
I'M SORRY YOU CAN'T DO WHAT YOU
THINK IS THE BEST IN
CONSULTATION WITH OUR DOCTOR
WHAT'S BEST FOR YOUR SON OR
DAUGHTER.
BECAUSE THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
SAID SO -- I I'M.
JUST VERY VERY -- CONFLICTED BY
THAT WHOLE THING YET.
I DO SEE THAT THERE ARE SOME
SITUATIONS WHERE.
SOMETHING -- IS NECESSARY TO DO
HERE I JUST DON'T THINK WE'VE
FOUND THE SWEET SPOT AND I WOULD
LIKE TO WORK WITH THE AUTHOR.
IF THIS DOESN'T GO THROUGH TODAY
TO TRY TO FIND WHAT THAT'S WEAK
SPOT IS.
THANK YOU US UNDER GOD --
SENATOR PAN.
THANKS VERY MUCH -- THE FIRST
FIVE ONE THANKS CENTER WINNER
FOR HIS -- HIS WORK IN THIS AREA
I THINK WHAT WE'VE HAD A CHANCE
TO TALK AND I WAS.
PLEASED TO SUPPORT THE
RESOLUTION -- I DO HAVE
SIGNIFICANT CONCERNS ABOUT THIS
BILL BECAUSE BASICALLY WE ARE
SAYING WITH THIS BILL -- AND I
THINK THERE I THINK THAT IT HAS
BEEN REYES THE OTHERS ALSO SOME --
I GUESS IS WOULD NEED
SIGNIFICANT CLARIFICATION AS
WELL BUT THAT BASICALLY A
PHYSICIAN'S LICENSE WOULD BE IN
JEOPARDY FOR WORKING WITH THE
PARENTS AND AND AND AND AND AND
BASICALLY AND TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT WHAT'S THE BEST YOU KNOW THE
STANDARD.
BASICALLY TRAVEL THE BEST SANTA
KERR AND I THINK IN A AND
ACTUALLY I A AGREE THAT.
AS MUCH AS POSSIBLE WHERE
[inaudible]
THE TRYING TO ENGAGE THE CHILD
ALL RIGHT -- IT IS IDEAL -- AND
DO THAT WHEN POSSIBLE WE SHOULD
TRY TO DO THAT SO I THINK THE
THE GOAL OF THE GOALS THAT
YOU'RE TRYING -- TO YOU IN THE
SPONSOR TO TRY TO ACHIEVE AYE
AYE SUPPORT -- BUT I FEEL THAT
THIS FILLED THE MECHANISM IS
UNFORTUNATELY ONE THAT HAS THINK
HAS A VERY SIGNIFICANT --
CONSEQUENCES IN THE END AND I
WOULD JUST I MEAN WE HAVE A FEW
QUESTIONS THAT TO CLARIFY AND WE
HAD SOME CONVERSATION ABOUT THIS
BILL SO.
AND WE'VE HEARD FROM THE
ACTUALLY WELL WHEN THE
OPPOSITION ARE ACTUALLY PARENTS
AND FAMILIES OF OF CHILDREN WITH
CONTROL YOUR HYPERPLASIA THIS
BILL SPECIFICALLY CALLS CALLS
OUT PATIENTS WITH THAT CONDITION
IF YOU HAD.
WHAT'S YOUR CONVERSATIONS WITH
THAT THAT THAT COMMUNITY --
SINCE THEY'RE ASSOCIATION AS
OPPOSED IN TERMS OF TRYING -- TO
TO ADDRESS THE THEIR CONCERNS.
YEAH WE'VE THEY'RE SUFFICIENT
I'M NOT SURE IF YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT THE CARES FOUNDATION BUT
FOUNDATION HAS A PRETTY
SIGNIFICANT HISTORY OF
HOMOPHOBIA -- SO I DON'T KNOW
WELL I AM VERY RESPECTFUL OF
INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE OPINIONS ON
THIS I DON'T.
THAT'S DIFFERENT IN TERMS OF AN
ASSOCIATION.
ON BOTH SIDES THREE REALLY CLEAR.
I'M NOT NONE OF US IS SAYING
THAT EVERY PERSON WHO UNDERGOES
THE SURGERY WHETHER IT'S FROM CH
OR NOW OTHER SITUATIONS THAT
EVERYONE.
IS DISSATISFIED CLEARLY THERE
ARE PEOPLE WHO ARE GLAD THAT
THEY HAD THE SURGERY.
BUT THE QUESTION AS ABOUT THE
PEOPLE WHO.
AREN'T WHO EITHER WERE ASSIGNED
THE WRONG GENDER.
OR HAVE PERMANENT PROBLEMS AS A
RESULT OF THE SURGERY.
AND EVEN IF AND THERE ARE SOME
DISPUTES ABOUT THE DATA BUT EVEN
IF WE ASSUME.
THAT A MAJORITY OF PEOPLE ARE
SATISFIED -- DOES NOT JUSTIFY
SUCH PROFOUNDLY NEGATIVE IMPACTS
FOR THE PEOPLE WHO WERE ASSIGNED
THE WRONG GENDER OR PERMANENT.
PROBLEMS -- AND IS THERE IN
TERMS OF THE HARM.
OF WAITING UNTIL A CHILD CAN
EXPRESS FOR THEMSELVES.
YOU KNOW GIVING INFORMED CONSENT
WHICH A YOUNG CHILD CAN PROVIDE
AND WE ADOPT EXISTING CALIFORNIA
LAW -- IN TERMS OF FOR CONSENT.
WHAT YOU BALANCE THE HARMS?
THIS IS NOT NO ONE SAYING THAT
THIS IS ALL COMPLETELY CLEAN CUT
IN ONE DIRECTION.
BUT THE QUESTION IS WHO'S BEING
HARMED SO COULD CARRY A CLEAR
FIGHT BECAUSE YOU SAID AND
INFORMED CONSENT.
WE DO ALLOW.
TEENAGERS -- TO WHO ARE MAINSTAY
MINERS AROUND BE PRODUCTIVE
HEALTH BUT NOT YOUNGER THAN THAT.
TERMS OF WHAT THEY CAN GIVE
CERTAINLY KNOWS A PEDIATRICIAN
DALY ACCIDENTALLY ASTOR OPINIONS
BUT THEY DON'T HAVE A LEGAL
STANDING TO PROVIDE CONSENT SO
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT DELAYING
SURGERY UNTIL.
UNTIL AGE FOURTEEN NOW WE'RE NOT
SO HOW SO HOW WOULD THAT
OPERATIONALIZE USABLE ON NOW SO
THIS IS NOT JUST.
YEAH I'M TALKING.
PATIENTS AND WHAT DO YOU THINK
AND YOUR EIGHT YEARS OLD I MEAN
DOUBLE THE THIS IS LOST SO.
YOUR CELL WERE.
GOING TO BE ALLOWING WERE WHAT.
WE'RE GOING TO BE.
ENSURING THAT THE CHILD COULD
NOT TO PARTICIPATE IN THE SEARCH
SO HOW WELL DEVELOPMENTALLY
WE'RE TALKING THEN ABOUT I THANK
YOUNG.
I THANK YOUNG CHILDREN OR AS WE
SEE MORE AND MORE ARE VERY MUCH
ABLE TO EXPRESS WHAT
PARTICULARLY WHAT THEIR GENDER
IS -- AND WHAT THEY WANT AND SO
WE'RE NOT TALKING ABOUT WAITING
UNTIL KIDS OR TEENAGER EIGHTEEN
YEARS OLD BUT WE KNOW THAT A
BABY CAN SAY ANYTHING -- AND OUT
TO WE'RE TRYING TO MOVE AWAY
FROM MY WILL ALSO JUST.
SAY SENATOR I APPRECIATE THE
QUESTION.
THAT IF WE HAD.
ANYONE TO NEGOTIATE WITH ON THIS
AND RESPECTFULLY TO SENATOR DODD --
YOU KNOW WE'VE HAD IN TERMS OF
THE OPPOSITION TO THE BILL --
THE OWNER NOT ABOUT YOU AND TALK
ABOUT THE OPPOSITE I'M TALKING
ABOUT THE MEDICAL ASSOCIATIONS
THAT FIGHT IF MY PHRASING WAS --
DAY I APOLOGIZE FOR THAT FOR THE
MEDICAL ASSOCIATIONS THE MEDICAL
ESTABLISHMENT HAS MADE CLEAR
THEY DON'T WANT TO WORK WITH US.
SO FOR MEDICAL NECESSITY OR
INFORMED CONSENT THESE VARIOUS --
YOU WERE GET CRITICIZED FOR
SAYING IT'S NOT IT'S NOT PRECISE
ENOUGH FOR IS WRONG.
AND I'M NOT OFFERING AN
ALTERNATIVE -- SAYING THIS IS
HOW IT SHOULD BE.
BECAUSE SOME HAVE SUGGESTED
INCLUDING MEMBERS THE
LEGISLATURE MAYBE THERE SHOULD
BE A SPECIFIC AGE WHERE THE
SURGERY CAN BE PERFORMED BECAUSE
THE CHILD IS ABLE TO EXPRESS.
AND WE MADE CLEAR THAT WERE OPEN
TO THOSE DISCUSSIONS BUT THEN
ONE NEVER ABLE TO ACTUALLY HAVE
THAT NEGOTIATION IN TERMS OF THE
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
WELL I I I THINK IT'S WELL I'M
IN CHIRLA ALSO DISCUSS INTO
DISARRAY THINK IT'S A BIT
PROBLEMATIC.
TO SAID THAT A LET'S SAY A
SECURE OLDER EIGHT YEAR OLD.
THAT THERE AND I THINK THIS BILL
REQUIRES A SIGNATURE AND SOME
OTHER THINGS.
THAT GIVEN THEIR DEVELOPMENTAL
STAGING THAT.
THAT WOULD HOLD UP.
A SURLY AND THEN AND CORD OR THE
MEDICAL BOARD OF CALIFORNIA --
BUT PERHAPS AT A QUESTION FOR
UROLOGIST I THINK WE HAD
ENDOCRINOLOGIST HERE -- CAN CAN
YOU SPEAK TO THE THE HOT BUTTON
WHAT WHAT WHAT ARE THE TRADE
OFFS -- FOR WAITING TILL
SOMEONE'S A TEENAGER.
YES AT WITH I AM MOSTLY
SURGERIES IS MORE PAIN FOR THE
PATIENTS.
A HIGHER RATE OF COMPLICATION --
A HIGHER RATE OF INFECTION WHEN
KIDS GO THROUGH PUBERTY THINGS
GET SWEATY DOWN THERE.
AND THERE IS THIS IS DEFINITELY
A HIGHER RATE OF INFECTION ALL
THAT WE DO -- THERE'S A AND THEN
A HIGHER LIKELIHOOD THAT THE
ONLY TO SECOND SURGERY -- KIDS
IT IN HAIFA STATUS THEY HAVE A
HIGHER RATE OF THE HOLDEN TIP
THE **** BECOMING THE AND SO I
ACTUALLY JUST TO CLARIFY THOUGH
I MEAN WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
SEVERAL DIFFERENT -- YES.
RIGHT ALL THESE INCREASED
INFECTION INCREASED BLEEDING
INCREASED PAIN -- BABIES OFTEN
DON'T NEED NARCOTICS AFTER
SURGERY -- WE HAVE AN OPIOID
CRISIS IN THIS COUNTRY -- EARLY
EXPOSURE NARCOTICS LENDS ITSELF
TO MORE DRUG USE TEENAGERS DO
NEED NARCOTICS AFTER THE
SURGERIES -- AND A POOR OUTCOMES
REPEAT SURGERY -- ACROSS THE
BOARD.
OKAY AND THEN OF THE
ENDOCRINOLOGIST THEN YOU'RE NOT
SURGEON SO WHITE WEDDING
ENDOCRINOLOGIST OPPOSED.
STATE HEARD FROM SEVERAL
PEDIATRIC ENDOCRINOLOGY
EXPRESSING THEIR CONCERNS.
THE PROBLEM IN MY MIND IS THAT
THIS IS AN EXTREMELY COMPLICATED
THERE'S EXTREMELY COMPLICATED
BIOLOGY SO THERE ARE MANY MANY
MOLECULAR RAMON ALL GENETIC.
PROBLEMS THAT CAN LEAD TO
GENITAL DIFFERENCES AND I DON'T
THINK WE CAN TREAT THEM ALL THE
SAME.
THAT'S MY MAIN OPPOSITION WE
SPEND A GREAT DEAL OF TIME
TRYING TO UNDERSTAND THE
DIAGNOSIS.
AND FROM WORKING THERE -- IN
TERMS OF AN INDIVIDUALIZED
MANAGEMENT PLAN THAT SOMETIMES.
NOT OFTEN BUT SOMETIMES INVOLVE
SURGERY.
AND SO I DON'T LIKE THAT WE'RE
TREATING EVERYTHING THE SAME.
OKAY THANK YOU.
THE SERVER DOCTOR WONG ALSO
RESPOND TO THAT FOR SURE.
I FIND IT A BIT SPUR YES -- FOR
MY COLLEAGUES TO REMARK ON ON
HOW ADULTS SURGERIES -- ARE MORE
MORE CHALLENGING -- BECUSE
THERE IS DOCUMENTED LITERATURE --
ON HOW CERTAIN IN CERTAIN HAND
TYPE OF SPEEDIEST REPAIRS HAVE
THE SAME.
RESULTS -- IN ADULTS AND
CHILDREN -- I HAVE A PAPER FROM
WARREN SNODGRASS HERE I'M FROM
SEVERAL YEARS AGO WHICH SAYS
EXACTLY THAT DESPITE POPULAR
OPINION THAT IS THE CASE -- AND
WE ALSO HAVE TO POINT OUT THAT --
PEDIATRIC UROLOGISTS ARE NOT THE
ONLY PEOPLE WHO ALTER WHO
OPERATE ON GENITALIA -- THAT YOU
KNOW THERE IS A GROWING --
COALITION OF SURGEONS WHO ARE
ABLE TO DO TEENAGE AND ADULT
TRANSGENDER SURGERY -- IN THESE
PATIENTS ARE ABLE TO CHOOSE
THEIR OWN BODIES -- AND WHO GO
THROUGH SURGERIES IN OUT NO
SURGERIES WITHOUT COMPLICATION
WE ALL KNOW THAT -- BUT THAT'S
TRUE ALSO OF INFERENCE SURGERIES
WHERE THERE ARE I I'VE HAD STORE
HEARD STORIES OF PEOPLE WHO HAD
BETUL PASSED HIS NERVE HAD THEIR
PARENTS HAD TO DILATE THEM.
WEEKLY UNTIL THEY THIRTEEN AND
IF WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
PSYCHOLOGICAL TRAUMA AND PAIN.
I I DON'T KNOW HOW YOU CAN
IGNORE THOSE STORIES AS WELL.
OKAY BUT CLARIFY WE HEARD GUESTS
YOU MUST IS ON YES -- FIVE THANK
YOU FOR KNOWLEDGE AND JUST FIRST
OFF -- WITH ALL DUE RESPECT
SENATOR WIENER THE CARES
FOUNDATION IS NOT HOME OF THICK
I KNOW THOSE PEOPLE I WOULD GO
TO THEM FAT FOR THEM SO I JUST
WANT TO CLARIFY THAT.
THANKS -- AND THEN THE SECOND
PART IN TERMS THE NOTION AS I
SAID IN MY IN MY STATEMENT.
THAT.
IT'S NOT THAT I'M FOR OR AGAINST
SURGERY IT'S THE FACT THAT THIS
IS SUCH A COMPLEX.
MATTER THAT EITHER WAY IT'S A
TOUGH CALL -- EITHER WAYS
UNFORTUNATELY NO ONE'S GOING TO
HAVE THE EXACT PERFECT OUTCOME
BUT ASSUMING EVERYONE'S THE SAME
AND AND NEGLECTING THE MENTAL
HEALTH IMPACTS OF POSSIBLY
DELAYING SURGERY AT LEAST ALL I
CAN SPEAK FOR CH -- BUT I'VE
SPOKEN TO C. H. INDIVIDUALS WHO
HAVE SAID THAT WAITING.
TILL EIGHTEEN OR NINETEEN WAS
THE WORST THING THAT COULD EVER
IMAGINE AND SOMETHING THEY WOULD
NOT WISH ON THEIR WORST ENEMY.
SO THE FACT THAT WE LIKE I SAID
THAT IT'S NOT THAT I DON'T WANT --
TO SIDE STEP ALL THE PEOPLE THAT
HAVE BEEN HURT BUT I THINK THIS
IS THE WRONG ANSWER TO A VERY
VERY COMPLEX MATTER.
I AGREE WITH ADRIAN.
CENTER AT THE FINISH.
OKAY WELL I DIED.
I GUESS ONE LAST GOOD FOR THE P.
R. KERALA JUST BECAUSE IT IS A
SITE I I SUPPORTED THE
RESOLUTION AND I THINK WE SHOULD
TRY TO THE LADY.
SURGERY WHEN THEY HAVE WILL FOR
ABLE -- TO THAT WHEN IT'S REASON-WAS THAT IT'S A COMPLEX DECISION
AND I THINK THAT'S WHAT WE'RE
HERE AND THE CHALLENGE HERE IS
WE'RE TRYING TO LEGISLATE.
PRACTICE MEDICINE AND THAT
ALWAYS YOU KNOW AND EVEN WITH
THE BEST INTENTIONS THAT OFTEN
DOESN'T -- YEAH PEOPLE GET
CAUGHT UP IN THAT.
CAN YOU PERHAPS SPEAK TO WHERE
IS THE PEDIATRIC UROLOGY
COMMUNITY IN TERMS OF THE ISSUES
THAT ARE THE THE THE THE BROADER
ISSUES ARE RAISED BY.
A CENTER WINNER AND INTERSECTS
COMMUNITY I ANY I THINK THEY DO
HAVE A POINT -- IN TERMS OF%
WHERE WE WILL TRY TO GET TO AYE
AYE I'VE CONCERNS ABOUT
LEGISLATING IT BUT BUT CAN BE
PERHAPS CAN YOU SPEAK TO THAT.
HOUSE OF CONCERNS ABOUT
LEGISLATING MEDICINE -- THINGS
HAVE CHANGED SO MUCH TIME EVEN
WHEN IN THE LAST FIVE TO TEN
YEARS -- ALMOST EVERY MAJOR
CENTER HAS A MULTI DISCIPLINARY
CLINIC.
ON REALLY AND THE NUMBERS WERE
TALKING ABOUT TRUE DST PATIENTS
TRUE INTERSEX PATIENCE IS
ESTIMATED BETWEEN THREE AND FIVE
KIDS IN CALIFORNIA YEAR.
AN ADMITTEDLY THOSE VERY COMPLEX
PATIENTS.
IT'S IT'S A HARD ANSWER WE DON'T
HAVE THE RIGHT -- ONE I CAN TELL
YOU THAT -- MY COLLEAGUES AND I
IN THE WHERE I TRAINED FOR
FELLOWSHIP AND EVEN WHERE I CAME
FROM FOR RESIDENCY.
SURGERY WHICH IS NOT THE
IMMEDIATE ANSWER WE DON'T WANT
TO BURN BRIDGES WE DON'T WANT TO
DO THINGS TO KIDS THAT WE THAT
CAN'T BE REVERSED -- THE
SURGERIES THAT WE'VE TALKED
ABOUT LARGELY TODAY ARE -- FOR
NORMAL FUNCTION AND BETTER
OUTCOMES MEDICALLY LIKE REDUCED
URINARY TRACT INFECTIONS -- AND
AND WE DO THOSE THINGS NOT TO
NORMALIZE -- A CHILD WE DO THOSE
THINGS TO HELP THEM FUNCTION --
AND SO WHEN YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
THOSE TRUE DST CASES -- WHICH I
THINK ARE ALSO IS ESTIMATED A
HUNDRED SURGERIES IN THE ENTIRE
UNITED STATES A YEAR.
I'M YOU YOU -- THOSE ARE
DIFFICULT I THINK EVERYONE'S
GONNA ADMIT THAT BUT I THINK THE
THING IS WE TRUST YOUR MEDICAL
PROVIDERS TRUST YOUR STATE BOARD
LICENSING PEOPLE THAT.
IN THESE MULTI DISCIPLINARY
CLINICS WERE IN A WORK TOGETHER.
AND WE'RE GOING TO FIND THE BEST
ANSWER -- EVERY SINGLE PHYSICIAN
THAT I KNOW ON THE QUESTION I
ALWAYS ASK EVERYBODY IS DO YOU
COME TO THE HOSPITAL YOU COME
THE HOSPITAL DATA DO.
AM I GOOD HOSPITAL EVERY DAY TO
HELP MY PATIENTS AND TO BE
PERFECT AND TO TAKE THE BEST
CARE POSSIBLE AND IN CHILDREN'S
HOSPITAL I WOULD SAY THAT YOU'RE
GONNA HAVE THAT UNANIMOUS ANSWER
EVERYWHERE.
I MOVED PAEDIATRICIAN PAEDIATRIC
PEOPLE WE GO INTO BECAUSE WE
LOVE KIDS WE LOVE HUMANITY AND
WE'RE GOING TO HELP THEM.
AND PUTTING A BILL LIKE THIS
THAT HIGHS ARE ARMS WE CAN'T
EVEN GIVE ALL THE OPTIONS.
ON LIKE I SAID BEFORE IT'S IT'S
REALLY ALARMING -- BECAUSE
PEOPLE DESERVE EDUCATION I A
100% AGREE WITH YOU SENATOR DODD
LIKE TEACH ONE REACH MANY.
BUT WE SHOULD BE EDUCATING ALL
THESE PEOPLE EVERYONE ABOUT DST
ABOUT INTERSEX AND AND THAT'S
HOW WE BECOME MORE ACCEPTING
THAT'S HOW WE GET FURTHER THAT'S
HOW WE ARRIVE.
AT BETTER DECISIONS AND THAT'S
HOW WE TAKE BETTER CARE OF ALL
HUMANS -- YOU KNOW IT'S IT'S A
DIFFERENT GAME.
THAN IT WAS BEFORE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU THE YEAH A
SENATOR HILL.
I THINK CENTER GALGIANI HAD HER
IN HER MICROPHONE OF FIRST
[inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
CENTER GALGIANI -- I WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR FOR
AUTHORING THE BILL AND I'VE CO
SPONSORED IT WITH YOU AND
ADMITTEDLY I KNEW VERY LITTLE
LIVE.
ACTUALLY CLOSE TO NOTHING ABOUT
THIS ISSUE AND TELL YOU BROUGHT
THE BILL FORWARD BUT AS SOMEONE
FROM THE LGBT COMMUNITY AND
SOMEONE WHO WAS BORN WITH
SCOLIOSIS A CURVE IN MY SPINE --
I KNOW I'M I'M JUST I'M
SENSITIVE TO THINGS THAT HAPPEN
AT BIRTH AND I WAS GOING TO ASK
THE QUESTION ORIGINALLY BUT I
THINK YOU SORT OF ANSWERED IT
BUT IT SEEMS TO ME THAT.
MOST OF US KNOW THAT AS YOUNG
CHILDREN WE HAVE OUR TONSILS
TAKEN OUT.
BECAUSE IT REDUCES INFECTIONS
WHEN WE'RE OLDER BUT THAT'S NOT
DONE IT BIRTH IT'S DONE.
WHEN?
CHILDREN ARE OLDER FIVE SIX
SEVEN I SUPPOSE -- MAYBE YOU CAN
ONCE AGAIN SPEAK TO WHY WHY
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT SO
COMMONLY DONE AND IT'S OKAY THAT
THAT GUY AND LATER.
IN LIFE BUT THURMOND AND SO DID
HAVE IT'S SO DIFFERENT.
WITH THESE TYPES OF SURGERIES
RESPECTFULLY ON TO TRY TO SAY MY
LAN I'MNOT NEAR NOSE AND THROAT
SURGEON -- BUT BUT I AM SOMEONE
WHO ALMOST HAD A TONSILLECTOMY
AS A YOUNG CHILD -- THAT'S
USUALLY DONE FOR INFECTION --
FOR SNORING -- FOR SLEEP APNEA --
SUE THAT'S THAT THAT THAT'S IT
TAT'S A DIFFERENT THAT'S A
DIFFERENT BALL GAME AND IT'S
AMAZING THAT YOU MENTION THAT
BECAUSE THE DECISIONAL THEM THE
MOST RECENT DECISION ALL REGRET
PAPER.
ACTUALLY TALK TO PAY TO PARENTS
ABOUT DECISIONAL REGRET AFTER
TONSILLECTOMY.
AND IT WAS 412409% OF PARENTS
HAD DECISIONAL REGRET AFTER
TONSILLECTOMY WHICH IF YOU LOOK
AT THE PAPERS FOR THE C. H. --
REGRET YOU'LL SEE ANYWHERE FROM
20% 240% WHICH IS ACTUALLY LOWER
THAN PARENTS REGRETTING
TONSILLECTOMY SO -- THERE'S THAT
AT BUT I THINK THAT.
THE THE QUESTION MEDICAL
NECESSITY AGAIN IT'S VERY STICKY.
AND IT'S VERY HARD TO DEFINE AND
I DON'T KNOW THAT.
IT'S POSSIBLE.
AS A LEGISLATIVE BODY TO DEFINE
THAT IN A WAY THAT WE DON'T HARM
SOME CHILDREN.
AND THERE ARE THERE ARE THERE
ARE DEFINITIONS OF MEDICAL
NECESSITY THIS ISN'T SOME SORT
OF VAGUE AMBIGUOUS THING.
AND YOU KNOW WE WE'VE HEARD
COMMENTS ABOUT A PERSON
STRUGGLES TO URINATE WERE.
HAVING PHYSICAL PAIN OR HAVING
YOUR AND THAT'S THAT'S ODD
PULLING IN TRAPPED IN YOUR ****.
THAT'S NOT WHAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT HERE DODD -- I THINK UNDER
ANY REASONABLE DEFINITION WOULD
BE MEDICAL NECESSITY AS I SAID
AT THE BEGINNING.
IF IF THE MEDICAL PROFESSION
THAT OPPOSING THE STOCK PRICE
AND SAY THE MEDICAL ASSOCIATIONS
ARE OPPOSE THE BILL.
HAVE A CONCERN THEY ONCE YOU'RE
CHANGING THE DEFINITION OF
MEDICAL NECESSITY THE WAY THAT
TYPICALLY WORKS IN THE
LEGISLATURE IS A COME FORWARD
AND SAY WE DON'T LIKE YOUR
DEFINITION.
HERE'S AN ALTERNATIVE DEFINITION
BECAUSE OBVIOUSLY IF SOMEONE IS
IN PAIN IF SOMEONE HAS -- URINE
PULLING IN EVERY CHINA AND CAN'T
URINATE OR MIGHT URINATE WHEN
THEY DON'T WANT TO URINATE.
IF SOMEONE -- IT IS REALLY
HAVING THOSE MEDICAL PROBLEMS
DOT IS MEDICALLY NECESSARY
THAT'S NOT WHAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT -- HERE -- AND I THINK
2240% REGRET IS ACTUALLY QUITE
SIGNIFICANT -- IN MY BOOK BRING
YOUR REVERSIBLE SURGERY -- AND I
DON'T KNOW IF I HEARD IN
CORRECTLY ABOUT QUOTE CHIU
INTERSECTS PATIENTS BEING --
THREE TO FIVE PER YEAR DOT DOTS
ODD THAT'S NOT ACCURATE IT'S NOT
EVEN CLOSE DR.
I HAVE A QUESTION.
ABOUT JOHNNY IT SEEMS LIKE MOST
OF THE DISPUTE IS AROUND WHAT
THE DEFINITION OF MEDICAL
NECESSITY IS AND PERHAPS.
YOU WILL CONSIDER IN ADDITION TO
THE BILL NOT INSTEAD OF BUT IN
ADDITION TO HAVING AN ADVISORY
TASK FORCE.
OF SOME SORT THAT WOULD MAKE
RECOMMENDATIONS TO THE MEDICAL
POURED FOR WHAT MEDICALLY
NECESSARY AND IN THESE INSTANCES
WE WILL BE OPEN TO THAT CAUGHT
OUR CONVERSATION.
ABSOLUTELY.
THE DOCTOR LONG HAS BEEN A I'M
GONNA WAIT SO IT IN LET'S SAY
THAT NEED TO BE RESPONSIVE TO
SENDER GALGIANI I WANT TO KEEP
MOVING TO THE PANEL SO.
WITH HER STATEMENT ABOUT
TONSILLECTOMY -- AND
SPECIFICALLY THE DATA USE YOU
SUGGESTED AND DECISIONAL REGRET
AND I WOULD LIKE TO POINT OUT
THAT THE DATA.
SUPPOSEDLY ON THE THAT THEY
ADMIT THAT THEY HAVE DONE ON
THIS JUST LOOK WRITTEN PEOPLE CH
WAS THAT WAS ACTUALLY SUPPOTED
BY THE CARES FOUNDATION NUMBER
ONE WHICH LEAVE THE TO IMPLICIT
BIAS IN NUMBER.
TWO THAT THE STUDY THAT SHE'S
REFERRING TO FROM THE UNIVERSITY
OF INDIANA I DOCTOR CON RESTOS
MANSKE WAS ACTUALLY A
RETROSPECTIVE REVIEW OF PATIENTS
WITH CH FROM THEIR CLINIC WHO
RESPONDED TO AN ONLINE SURVEY.
THIS IS COMPARED -- TO
TONSILLECTOMY DATA THAT WAS DONE
IN A PROSPECTIVE CONTROLLED
PROSPECTIVE CONTROLLED TRIAL
WE'RE PATIENTS WERE GIVEN THE
OPTION TO HAVE SURGERY AND OR
NOT IT IS NOT SOMETHING THAT CAN
BE COMPARED DIRECTLY.
AND I WANTED TO BRING THIS UP
BECAUSE IT'S AN EXAMPLE I THINK
OF WHAT IS ONE OF THE MOST
RAMPANT.
MOST DISAPPOINTING THINGS TO ME
AS BEING A UROLOGIST AS A
SCIENTIST AND A MOTHER -- BEING
INVOLVED IN THIS FIELD IS IS
THAT REPORT RELATIVE
INTELLECTUAL DISHONESTY MOST OF
MY COLLEAGUES IN THE WAY THAT
THEY PRESENT DATA.
AND INTERPRET DATA.
OKAY CENTER GOALS ANYTHING ELSE.
ALL RIGHT AT CENTER HILL AND
CENTER LATE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER CHAIR AND AND THANK YOU --%
SENATOR WIENER FOR FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP IN THIS AND I
CERTAINLY RECALL THE ISSUE OF
LAST YEAR AND AS YOU CAN FOR THE
RESOLUTION AND CERTAINLY
SUPPORTED IT.
AND DOCTOR I I APPRECIATE YOUR
COMMENTS THAT YOU GET GO TO WORK
EVERY MORNING YOU THERETO HELP
THEIR PATIENTS IN THAT SUCH A
WONDERFUL.
THING AND I THINK JUST IN THIS
ROOM AND AND SITTING UP HERE
EVERYONE OF US.
I THINK FEELS THE SAME WAY WHEN
WE COME TO WORK -- IN SIT IN
THIS ROOM AND IN THAT OTHER ROOM
THAT'S BEHIND THIS -- IT'S IT'S
VERY IMPORTANT FOR THAT -- TO
AND AND I ALSO WANT TO THANK
WHICH MARKS THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR VERY MEANINGFUL AND
POWERFUL.
OF IT IN IN I. N. ALSO IS A LOOK
THROUGH THE ANALYSIS THAT THE
THE VERY CAPABLE STAFF.
PUT TOGETHER THE SAME QUESTIONS
THAT I THINK WE'VE HEARD TODAY
ARE RAISED IN HERE IS SOME OF
THE SAME QUESTIONS THAT WE HEARD
FROM THE OPPOSITION ABOUT.
A DEFINING THE YOU KNOW
MEDICALLY NECESSARY AND HOW WE
WOULD DO THAT AND HOW HOW YOU
WOULD.
THE TERMINOLOGY -- OF MEDICAL
NECESSITY IT'S TOO LIMITING AND
THE CLINICAL JUDGMENT AND HOW WE
WOULD COME TO THAT AND WHICH
WOULD PROBABLY MOST TROUBLING S
THESE ARE DEFINITIONAL ISSUES
THAT WE'RE TRYING TO CREATE AN
CRAFT.
AND THEN AS I LOOK AT THE LETTER
FROM THE CALIFRNIA MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION IS PROBABLY WHEN I
HEAR THAT THEY HAVE NOT BEEN
WILLING.
OR ANYONE HAS BEEN WILLING TO
SIT DOWN AND NEGOTIATE THEIR
PERHAPS THE CLARIFICATION OR THE
DEFINITIONS THAT WE'RE LOOKING
AT BECAUSE I THINK THAT'S WHERE.
THERE'S ROOM HERE TO COME TO
SOME AGREEMENT ON THAT AND WHICH
TROUBLING TO IS A READ IT SAYS
ON BEHALF OF THE THIS IS THE
LETTER FROM THIS THE CMA.
ON BEHALF OF THE MORE THAN FORTY
FOUR THOUSAND MEMBERS OF THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION I
THINK THEY'RE HUNDRED SEVENTY
FIVE THOUSAND LICENSE PHYSICIANS
IN CALIFORNIA SO THEY REPRESENT.
SMALL PORTION OF THAT NUMBER IS
THERE A GROUP SOMEWHERE.
THEY CAN SIT DOWN AND NEGOTIATE
AND LOOK FOR SOMETHING WORKING
WITH THE CHAIR OF THIS COMMITTEE --
AND IN THE COMMITTEE THAT CAN.
OF CRAFT THOSE DEFINITIONS I
THINK IF YOU'RE RESPONSIBLE TO
WALK AWAY FROM THAT ESPECIALLY
IN LIGHT OF THE FACT WITH THE
RESOLUTION CALLED FOR LAST YEAR.
AND THE SUPPORT THAT I THINK --
WE HAVE FOR SOME.
SOME FUTURE OF SOME.
SOME COMPROMISE IN THIS AND I
THINK THE DEFINITIONS AS MISS
MARCH WAS TALKING ABOUT THE MEAN
THEIR SOMETHINGS THAT APPLIANCE
SOMETHING'S IT SHOULDN'T APPLY.
OF ED IN HIGH DIED -- I'M GOING
TO SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY
BECAUSE I THINK I WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT IT DOES MOVE SO THAT
WE CAN GET [inaudible]
THOSE.
QUESTIONS THOSE DEFINITIONS
ANSWERED IN SOLVED IN SOME FORM
BEFORE IT GETS TO THE FLOOR AND
AND HOWEVER WAS FORWARD SO I
APPRECIATE THIS THIS
CONVERSATION AND DISCUSSION --
BUT IT -- IT IS A IT'S
UNFORTUNATE THAT WE CAN'T SIT
DOWN WITH THE PROFESSION -- THAT
IS -- RESPONSIBLE FOR MANY OF
THESE DECISIONS AND AND GET TO
THAT.
THAT PLACE.
ANSWER HAVE I MAY DISCOVER ONE
BANK THIS MARKS ACTUALLY HAS
BEEN WILLING TO TALK TO SOME OF
OUR FOLKS AND SO I WANNA SAID NO
ONE ON BUT IN TERMS OF THE
MEDICAL SO THAT IT IS NOT A
LUXURY NINE ARE SMART AND MARK
THEM VERY GRACIOUSLY.
AND I APPRECIATE THAT I MY
CONCERN WAS THAT -- THAT THAT
THOSE WHO WE LOOK TOWARDS TO TO
BE PART OF THAT CONVERSATION AND
IF THEY HAVE NOT THAT'S THAT'S
TROUBLING [inaudible]
WEBSITE [inaudible]
WE HAVE.
THE AUTHORS OF THE BILL AS WELL
WE HAVE HAD CONVERSATIONS WITH
STAFF.
WE HAD TWO MONTHS OF TRYING TO
GET CA H. EXEMPTED FROM A SIMPLE
RESOLUTION LAST YEAR THAT THAT
THAT THE AUTHOR WOULDN'T TAKE IN
THAT RESOLUTION SO WE HAVE HAD
CONVERSATIONS I JUST WANT TO BE
CLEAR THAT THIS IS NOT THAT WE
HAVE NEVER HAD CONVERSATIONS.
IT HAS COME UP IT'S A
COMPLICATED ISSUE FUNDAMENTALLY
THOUGH WE DO HAVE DIFFERENCES.
OF THEY WANT TO LEGISLATE THE
PRACTICE OF MEDICINE AND
CONSIDER THINGS LIKE HYPOSPADIAS
AND C. H. AS INTERSEX.
THE REALITY IS WE FUNDAMENTALLY
DON'T AGREE WITH THAT.
THEY WANT TO ALLOW THEY DON'T
THEY DON'T WANNA HAVE PARENTS
INVOLVED IN THE DECISION WE
FUNDAMENTALLY DISAGREE WITH THAT.
THE DEFINITION OF MEDICAL
NECESSITY WE FUNDAMENTALLY
DISAGREE WITH THOSE TO CENTER
HELD YOU KNOW I I THINK A LOT
ABOUT YOU AND WE'VE WORKED A LOT
TOGETHER -- THERE ARE TIMES WHEN
YOU HAVE TO AGREE TO DISAGREE
OKAY AND THIS IS ONE OF THOSE
ISSUES OKAY -- I'M GONNA GO TO
IS CENTER LEYVA BUT BEFORE I DO
THAT I WANT TO LEAST RESPOND TO
WITH A THOUGHTFUL COMMENTS FROM
MY COLLEAGUE SENATOR HILL.
I AGREE WITH MUCH OF WHAT YOU
HAVE SAID.
AND I THINK IT'S A POINT OF
FRUSTRATION FOR ME.
AND I THINK FOR OUR THE
COMMITTEE STAFF AND OTHERS IS
THAT.
THERE SEEMS TO BE ROOM TO FIND
SOME COMMON GROUND HERE AND ALL
THE PARTNERS HAVE NOT BEEN
WILLING TO PUT THAT.
THINGS ON THE TABLE AND TRY TO
CARVE OUT.
DEFINITIONS MORE CONCISELY IT'S
PART OF WHY I THINK THIS.
BILL IS IS NOT READY AT THE
MOMENT -- BUT I I AM I HAVE
CAUTIOUS OPTIMISM THAT IF WE CAN
KEEP WORKING ON IT THAT WE CAN
TRY TO FIND THAT THAT SPACE.
BECAUSE OF THAT THAT THAT THE
COMMON GOALS WE ALL HAVE FOR THE
HEALTH OF OUR KIDS SO IT IS A
POINT OF FRUSTRATION -- EVEN
THOUGH I HAVE I HAVE SOME AS YOU
KNOW RELUCTANCE ABOUT -- MOVING
THE BILL HAD TODAY.
SENATOR LEYVA.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR GOOD
AFTERNOON THANK YOU TO BOTH
SIDES FOR BEING HERE THIS IS
WHAT DEMOCRACY LOOKS LIKE --
THIS IS A HARD SUBJECT THIS IS
THIS IS DIFFICULT I READ THIS
BOOK.
IN PREPARATION FOR TODAY AND I
READ ALL OF THE OPPOSITION
LETTERS AND I READ.
OF FROM THE THREE SURGEON
GENERAL'S ALSO THAT I COULD TRY
AND HELP MAKE AN INFORMED
DECISION.
I TO LOVE MY JOB AND I TO EVERY
DAY GO TO WORK HOPING I CAN
CHANGE LIVES BETTER FOR THE
BETTERMENT OF OF FOLKS IN
CALIFORNIA.
IN TO THE HUMAN RIGHTS BOOK
AROUND ONE IN TWO THOUSAND
BABIES IS DIFFERENT ENOUGH THE
DOCTORS MAY RECOMMEND SURGICAL
INTERVENTION INTERVENTION SO ONE
IN.
TWO THOUSAND THAT'S THAT'S NOT
THAT THAT'S A LOT OF BABIES -- I
THINK IT'S A DIFFICULT SUBJECT.
BUT SENATOR WIENER.
ARE YOU SAYING THAT IF IT'S
MEDICALLY AN NECESSARY.
BATS WITH THE SURGERY SHOULDN'T
HAPPEN ON A CHILD'S AT WHICH A
BILL SAYING.
ON A BABY CON A BABY HAS
ACTUALLY.
BUT SO AND THEN MY QUESTION FOR
THE MEDICAL -- GROUP WOULD BE IF
IT'S NOT MEDICALLY NECESSARY AT
THE TIME THE CHILD IS BORN WHY
IS WAITING A PROBLEM.
AND JUST TO REFER TO MY PREVIOUS
COMMENTS -- I THINK THE CHILDREN
EXPERIENCE MORE PAIN OR
COMPLICATIONS -- AND THEN THERE
NEED FOR SURGERY THE SECOND
SURGERY INCREASES -- AS THEY GET
OLDER IN MY OWN EXPERIENCE AND
IN.
A LOT OF OUR LITERATURE LE
HENSLEY PAPER I KNOW THAT YOU
KNOW THAT WHEN DOCTOR WONG --
AND EVEN IN MY MOST RECENT
RECENT EXPERIENCE AND GONNA WE
OPERATED ON KIDS THAT WERE THE
SIX TO TWELVE MONTHS OF AGE
OPERATE YOUNG KIDS UP -- TO
TWENTY AND THE KIDS WHO WERE
TEENAGERS OLDER EVEN THE THREE
AND FOUR YEAR OLDS HAD A HIGHER
RATE OF COMPLICATION -- AND
ALTHOUGH ANECDOTAL -- I THINK
THAT IT THE HENCE THE PAPER
SHOWED THAT DEMONSTRATED THAT
THERE IS ANOTHER PAPER I THINK
FROM CANADA THE DEMONSTRATED
THAT -- AND SO WE KNOW THAT IT'S
HARDER FOR THE CHILDREN TO DELAY
SURGERY.
IN RESPONSE TO HURT HER REMARK
TO ME I AM AWARE THAT PAPER AND
THAT THE PAPER FROM TWO THOUSAND
AND ONE USING -- TECHNIQUES THAT
ARE SOMEWHAT OUTDATED.
WHAT'S INTERESTING IS THAT I
THINK THEIR TOTAL THIRTY FIVE
PATIENTS IN THAT COUNTRY IN THAT
STUDY IN OVERALL THERE WAS A
HIGHER RATE EVERY OPERATION
EXCEPT IF WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE
SUBGROUP ANALYSIS.
ONLY EIGHT OF THOSE PATIENTS
WERE ACTUALLY DINOVO HYPOSPADIAS
IN OTHER WORDS ONLY EIGHT HAD
NEVER HAD PREVIOUS SURGERY SO
EIGHT THOSE OF THOSE EIGHT
PEOPLE THERE WAS A 100% SUCCESS
RATE AFTER TWO SURGERIES WHERE'S
THE REMAINING PATIENTS WHO HAVE
HAD PREVIOUS.
INFANT SURGERIES YES THEY HAD
HIGHER COMPLICATION RATES WE
JUST WANTED TO POINT OUT AGAIN
THAT -- INTERPRETATION F
MEDICAL DATA CAN BE VERY BIASED
BASED ON PEOPLE'S PEOPLE'S OWN
OPINIONS THANK YOU AND I DID
WANT TO SAY ALSO THAT WE WE
HEARD I CAN'T REMEMBER WHO SAID
IT BUT SOMEONE WAS TALKING ABOUT
REFERRING TO STUDIES THIRTY
YEARS AGO FORTY YEARS AGO.
EVERYTHING IN HERE HAPPENED
WITHIN THE LAST THREE TO FOUR
YEARS AND WHEN THEY YOU KNOW ONE
MOTHER TALKED ABOUT I I THINK
THIS IS ABOUT EDUCATION.
I I'M NOT A DOCTOR BUT I HAVE
CHILDREN I NEVER THOUGHT TWENTY
SEVEN YEARS AGO WHEN OUR TWINS
WERE BORN THAT WE COULD HAVE AN
INTEREST TAX CHILD I WISH
SOMEONE HAD SAID THAT WE DIDN'T.
BUT WHAT WHAT IF WE DID AND WE
HAD NO KNOWLEDGE WE HAVE NO
UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT WE SHOULD
OR SHOULDN'T DO FOR THIS CHILD.
SO I THINK EDUCATION IS
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT AND TALKING
TO PARENTS WHEN THERE ARE ABOUT
TO HAVE A CHILD THAT YOUR CHILD
TO BE BORN EXIST OR WHEN YOUR
CHILD IS BORN LIKE THIS THE
FIRST THING YOU SAY IS
CONGRATULATIONS.
YOU HAVE A HEALTHY CHILD WHO
LOOKS A LITTLE DIFFERENT THAN
SOME OTHER CHILDREN DO BUT WE'RE
GONNA WE'RE GONNA WORK ON THAT
TOGETHER.
MY WORRY IS THAT.
IT WE'RE WE'RE SUPPOSED TO GET
BETTER AS A SOCIETY AND WHEN I
READ SOME OF THE STORIES ABOUT.
ABOUT CHILDREN WHAT WE PUT IN
THEM PUT THEM THROUGH AND THEY
HAVEN'T HAD ANY OPPORTUNITY I
THINK CA AT AGE IS A LITTLE
DIFFERENT -- I'D LIKE TO SEE US
I THINK WHAT I HEAR YOU SAYING
FOR OPEN TO WORKING ON THINGS.
I WORRY THAT IF YOU HAVE NOT HAD
THAT SURGERY -- EARLIER THAN
WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO PREVENT
COULD HAPPEN TO YOU CAN'T GO TO
KINDERGARTEN TO BE WAITING YOUR
PANTS ALL YOUR PEERS WITH THINK
THERE WAS SOMETHING WRONG WITH
YOU WE WOULDN'T WANT THAT -- SO
I HOPE THAT WE CAN LOOK AT THAT
ASPECT BUT YOU KNOW.
I NGUYEN IN READING THE STUDY OF
ONE MOTHER SAID TO SHARE SIX
TOWN SHE JUST SAID SOMEONE ELSE
WHY HER SON LOOK DIFFERENT.
THAT'S JUST THE WAY HE WAS BORN
AND HE LOOKS DIFFERENT DOWN
THERE.
AND WHY DO WE SO AS A SOCIETY
WANT TO MAKE SURE EVERYONE
CONFORMS.
WHEN YOU'RE BORN YOU'RE BORN THE
WAY YOU ARE?
SO I I FEEL LIKE I'M KIND OF
RAMBLING BUT I ALSO JUST THINK
AS AS A SOCIETY WE'RE SUPPOSED
TO GET BETTER WHEN YOU TALKED
ABOUT CONVERSION THERAPY I'M SO
GLAD THAT I WAS HERE TO GET TO
BE A PART OF BANNING THAT.
AS A MOTHER OF A GATE CHILD IF
MY DAUGHTER BEEN BORN TWENTY
YEARS AGO SHE PROBABLY WOULD
HAVE BEEN TOLD THERE WAS
SOMETHING WRONG WITH HER --
WHICH OF COURSE THERE'S NOTHING
WRONG WITH HER SHE'S GETTING
MARRIED IN THE FALL TO A WOMAN
SHE'S JUST HPPY SHE CAN BE SHE
SIX SUCCESSFUL WOMAN.
BUT I WORRY THAT WE ARE DOING
THE SURGERIES UNNECESSARILY ON
THESE CHILDREN AND THEY DON'T
HAVE ANY SAY EXACTLY WHAT THE
AUTHOR HAS SAID.
SO ALL OF THAT TO SAY I WANT TO
SEE THE I WILL VOTE FOR THE BILL
TODAY I WANT TO SEE IT MOVE OUT
I HOPE THERE'S SOME WORK WE CAN
DO I HOPE THAT -- THAT CMA AND
AM A WILL COME TO THE TABLE
BECAUSE I UNDERSTAND THERE
SOMETIMES BUT FUNDAMENTAL
DISAGREEMENTS -- BUT THIS
AFFECTS A LOT OF PEOPLE AND A
LOT OF PEOPLE'S LIVES SOME THANK
YOU FOR BRINGING FOR THE
FILLINGS HAVE THIS DISCUSSION
TODAY.
GRAY ANY OTHER -- COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
CENTER WINNER BEFORE I HAVE YOU
CLOSE I WOULD LIKE TO ASK FOR A
FIVE MINUTE RECESS SO WE'LL BE
BACK IN FIVE MINUTES
OKAY THANK YOU FOR THE THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR THAT RECESS --
BEFORE I AGREE I BRING IT BACK
TO SENATOR WINNER TO CLOSE I
WANT TO SEE IF THERE'S ANY OTHER
FURTHER COMMENTS FROM THE DAY AS
CENTER GALGIANI.
YOU KNOW I I BROUGHT UP EARLIER
ABOUT WHETHER THE AUTHOR MIGHT
AN ADVISORY BOARD TO MAKE
RECOMMENDATIONS ON ON AND WITH
THE PROCEDURES INVOLVED IN THIS
SPACE HOW THEY'RE DIFFERENT FROM
THE DEFINITION OF MEDICALLY
NECESSARY IN STATUTE OR WHATEVER
THAT IS.
I THINK THIS CHALLENGE THAT --
MY COLLEAGUES ARE HAVING IS THAT
WE DON'T KNOW ENOUGH ABOUT.
WHAT IS MEDICALLY NECESSARY
WHAT'S NOT CERTAINLY SENATOR PAN
HAS MUCH BROADER KNOWLEDGE THAN
MOST OF US ON THIS COMMITTEE
HERE BUT?
I FEEL THAT WERE VERY CLOSE TO
SENATOR HILL SAID AND YOU WERE
WILLING -- TO CONSIDER PUTTING
TOGETHER AN ADVISORY BOARD IN
THIS CAPACITY TO ADVISE ON THIS --
SO I'M HOPING AND WOULD LIKE TO
ASK YOU IF IF YOU WOULD.
TAKE AN AMENDMENT TO THE BILL TO
CREATE THIS ADVISORY BOARD SAID
THAT.
WE HAVE PROFESSIONALS.
COMING UP WITH THOSE DECISIONS.
I'M THERE THE ANSWER IS YES
CENTER  APPRECIATE THAT AND WE
ALSO OF COURSE STAND READY TO
WORK WITH THE MEDICAL
ASSOCIATIONS.
ON ANY SUGGESTIONS THEY HAVE
ABOUT THE FINING MEDICAL
NECESSITY IF THEY HAVE CONCERNS
ABOUT THE EXISTING DEFINITION --
BUT THE ANSWER IS YES THANK YOU.
SO -- I GUESS MY MY RESPONSE TO
THAT SENATOR THAT CONSTRUCTIVE
SUGGESTIONS CENTER CALLED JOHNNY
IS C. THANK YOU.
THEY WERE ALL TRYING TO FIND THE
SPACE IS COMMON GROUND SPACE.
AND I THINK IF IT MEANS THAT WE
TAKE IN ANOTHER WEEK AND WORK
THROUGH YOUR THOUGHTS -- WITH
THE AUTHOR AND WITH WITH THE
COMMITTEE STAFF.
WE CAN SEE WHETHER WE HAVE
SOMETHING THAT MIGHT BE IN THE
RIGHT FORM FOR US TO TO CONSIDER --
NEXT WEEK ON THIS ISSUE.
AT THAT IS THAT THE DIRECTION IN
WHICH YOU'RE HEADING.
I THINK IT'S ONE THAT I CAN
SUPPORT AND ENCOURAGE.
ALL RIGHT.
ALL RIGHT WITHOUT THAT FURTHER
DO THAT LET'S FINAL COMMENT
CENTER PAN.
SO I THINK ONE OF THE CONCERNS
IS THAT -- BASICALLY IN THE BILL
SAYS DOING THIS IS
UNPROFESSIONAL CONDUCT WHICH
MEANS YOU'RE THREATENING LICENSE
OF A PHYSICIAN AND EVEN.
AND IT BUT FIRST THE TREATMENT
SO IT'S FAIRLY BROAD SO IT.
ALSO MEANS THAT -- I MEAN IT'S
NOT CLEAR I MEAN SOME OF THESE
CAN SAY MEDICAL NECESSITY BUT
SOME OF IT ALSO -- I THINK
RACISM CHALLENGES FOR PHYSICIANS
TO KNOW YELP BUT WHAT POINTER
LICENSE MIGHTBE THREATENED --
WOULD YOU BE WILLING TO REMOVE
THE SECTION ON A PROFESSIONAL
CONDUCT.
I'M WE ARE ABSOLUTELY OPEN THE
CONVERSATION ABOUT CONSEQUENCES
AND WHAT THE ENFORCEMENT
MECHANISM IS IS -- AND MAKING
SURE THAT THERE IS AN INCENTIVE
FOR PEOPLE TO ACTUALLY FOLLOW
THE LAW SO WE'RE HAPPY TO HAVE
THAT GENERAL CONVERSATION. TO
SEE IF WE CAN COME TO A
RESOLUTION ON IT -- AND WHAT
THAT AUTUMN A RESOLUTION WOULD
BE -- I'D I CAN SAY BUT AS A SAY
IT TAKES TWO TO TANGO.
AND WE AGAIN IN BY -- THE
MEDICAL ASSOCIATIONS -- TO
ACTUALLY WORK WITH US ON THESE
ISSUES SUCH AS A CLEAR FOR YOU
WOULD BE OPEN TO REMOVING
SECTION I PROFESSIONAL CONDUCT I
AM I AM OPEN TO A DISCUSSION
ABOUT WHAT THE ENFORCEMENT
MECHANISM IS AND WHAT THE
CONSEQUENCES WOULD BE FOR
VIOLATING.
THE LAW I CANSAY HERE TODAY THE
DOT WILL BE REMOVING THIS -- BUT
WE'RE OPEN TO THAT CONVERSATION
NOT RULING ANYTHING OUT.
WE WELCOME THAT CONVERSATION
BECAUSE I UNDERSTAND THAT THAT
IS A CONCERN I HEAR THAT -- HER
I'VE HEARD THAT BEFORE AND I
HEAR IT AGAIN TODAY AND I HEAR
WHAT I UNDERSTAND YOU'RE WHAT
YOU'RE SAYING SENATOR -- BUT
WE'RE OPEN TO THAT CONVERSATION
I CAN SEE WHAT THE FINAL RESULT
WILL BEBECAUSE THAT WILL BE.
AS A RESULT OF DIALOGUE AND
NEGOTIATION WORK COLLABORATIVELY
WHICH HAS NOT HAPPENED TODAY ON
THIS LEGISLATION MR BACK WAS
RIGHT LAST YEAR ON THE
RESOLUTION -- CMA DID WORK WITH
US AND WE APPRECIATE THAT -- BUT
THIS YEAR IT'S BEEN A VERY VERY
DIFFERENT APPROACH AND AGAIN.
ANYONE HAS A RIGHT TO
CATEGORICALLY OPPOSED ANYTHING
THEY WANT THIS ISN'T A CRITICISM
OR SAYING THAT IT'S SOMEHOW ON
PROFESSIONAL TO DO THAT BUT
THAT'S THE APPROACH OF THE TAKEN
AND IT HAS HINDERED.
OUR ABILITY TO HAVE THESE KINDS
OF DISCUSSIONS I WOULD JUST SAY
THAT I THINK THAT THE
FUNDAMENTAL ISSUE.
THE ADDRESS THANK YOU.
OKAY ALL RIGHT THANK YOU SENATOR
PAN.
SENATOR WIENER AYE MINUTE AT
TAKE THE DISCRETION OF THE CHAIR
TO SAY THANK YOU TO UP MY
COLLEAGUES THANK YOU TO YOUR
WITNESSES.
BOTH IN FAVOR AND AGAINST THE
DOCTORS HAVE TRAVELED HERE FROM
FAR.
AND WIDE -- THOSE WHO HAD THESE
EXPERIENCES TO SHARE WITH US.
THEIR STORIES I THOUGHT IT WAS
VERY IN DEPTH AND THOUGHTFUL
HEARING ON A VERY SENSITIVE
SUBJECT IN WHICH I THINK ALL OF
US SHARE THE SAME GOAL.
WHICH IS PATIENT CARE AND DOING
THE RIGHT THING -- FOR FOLKS --
IN WHATEVER CONDITION LIFE THAT
WITH THAT THEY ARE HERE -- AND
SO WITH THAT I WANT TO SAY THANK
YOU -- WE'RE GONNA AT THE FOR
THIS -- ISSUE.
THESE FOR OTHER WEEK WILL GO AND
WORK TOGETHER -- AND SEE IF WE
CAN FIND A A PATHWAY THAT TO
INCORPORATE SOME OF THE CONCERNS
AND IDEAS THAT SENATOR GALGIANI
AND OTHERS HAVE RAISED.
AS FOR CLARIFICATIONS OF THE
COURT IS SAYING WE'RE NOT THAT
THE COMMITTEE WILL NOT BE VOTING
TODAY.
THAT WOULD NOT BE THE DIRECTION
THAT WE'RE HEADING RIGHT NOW YES
OKAY SO IT'S BEING TAKEN OFF
WE'RE GOING TO DEFER THIS AND
THAT AND WE'LL SEE IF WE CAN GET
THE ISSUE IN SHAPE.
FOR ANOTHER ANOTHER HEARING AND
CONSIDERATION NEXT WEEK OKAY SO
THE IT WOULD DEPEND THE AGENDA
IS FOR NEXT WEEK NEXT MONDAY YES
SIR.
OKAY AND I BELIEVE THAT THAT'S
THE LAST.
UPDATE TO THIS COMMITTEE COULD
HERE BECAUSE IT IS DOUBLE
REFERRED.
UNDER A CAR WITHOUT WILL WAIVERS
I THINK THE YOU ARE CORRECT OKAY --
I BOUGHT WHILE I AM NOT AGREED
WITH THAT DECISION I RESPECTED
TERRACE PRAGUE TO DO THAT AND WE
WILL WORK IN EARNEST AND IN GOOD
FAITH WITH THE CHAIR AND WITH
ANY STAKEHOLDER THE ONCE
PARTICIPATED.
THANK YOU AGAIN THANK AYE
CENTERS WE ARE THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR I JUST HAVE A QUESTION SO
THAT MEAN WHEN WE RECONVENE ON
MONDAY OF NEXT WEEK WE'LL JUST
BE HERE FOR A VOTE ONLY.
WELL I'M GONNA SEE WHETHER
THERE'S AN AMENDMENT THAT CAN BE
CRAFTED THAT TAKES INTO ACCOUNT
THE THE THOUGHTFUL FEEDBACK THAT
WE'VE GOTTEN HERE TODAY.
AND DEPENDING ON THAT CONDITION
OF THAT POTENTIAL AMENDMENT IT
WOULD BE SET FOR A HEARING.
WITH THE BILL AS AMENDED OR AS
AS A VOTE ONLY ON THAT MEASURE
THAT'S BEFORE US I JUST WORRY
ABOUT ALL THE WITNESSES ON BOTH
SIDES THAT TRAVEL TO BE HERE
TODAY AND WOULD HAVE TO TRY AND
BE BACK NEXT MONDAY.
THAT'S HOW I ENCOURAGE THEM TO
STAY IN TOUCH WITH THE AUTHOR OF
THE COMMITTEE STAFF AND WE'LL DO
OUR BEST.
TO KEEP THEM INFORMED ABOUT HOW
THINGS ARE GOING.
THANK YOU VERY GOOD OKAY.
VERY GOOD THANK YOU OFF.
CHECK A CLOCK HERE WE'VE GOT
FIFTEEN MINUTES BEFORE SESSION
AGAIN SENATOR MONEY'S BEEN VERY
PATIENT TO WAIT.
IF YOU WANT TO COME BACK.
ALL RIGHT.
AS WELL AS THE ROOM GETS CLEARED --
AND WE GET SET PERCENT OF
REMINDING WE AYE CENTER HILL HAS
A MOTION TO APPROVE THE CONSENT
CALENDAR MEMBERS.
EACH WITH A MOTION TO APPROVE
THE CONSENT COUNTER AND IF THE
SECRETARY WOULD TAKE THE ROLE
GLAZER BY GLAZER AYE CHIANG.
CHIANG AYE ARCHULETA ARCH LET
AYE DODD.
NOT AYE GALGIANI GALGIANI AYE
HILL.
WELL I LEYVA.
LEYVA AYE PAN HI CAN I WILL HI.
THE NINE OKAY THE CONSENT
CALENDAR IS OUT NINE TWO ZERO
CENTER MINING THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE -- THIS AFTERNOON WELL
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS I
THINK I BRING YOU A LESS
CHALLENGING BILL.
THE BILL.
THANK YOU -- I WILL PRESENT
HOWEVER SB -- THREE NINETY ONE
THE BEER OF HOUSEHOLD GOODS AND
SERVICES OVERSEAS AND REGULATES
HOUSEHOLD MOVERS BY CONTRACTING
SPECIAL INVESTIGATORS TO CITE
MOVERS WHO VIOLATE THE LAW.
TWENTY SEVENTEEN SB NINETEEN BY
SENATOR HILL TRANSFERRED
OVERSIGHT OF HOUSEHOLD MOVERS
FROM THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION TO THE
BUREAU OF HOUSEHOLD GOODS AND
SERVICES.
UNDER THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF CONSUMER AFFAIRS.
WHEN SB NINETEEN TRANSFERRED
OVERSIGHT OF HOUSEHOLD MOVERS
FROM THE PC TO BE H. G. S. THE
BILL DID NOT EXPRESSLY TRANSFER
AUTHORITY TO ISSUE?
A NOTICE TO APPEAR IN COURT TO
BE AGE GSS SPECIAL INVESTIGATORS
DUE TO A TECHNICAL OVERSIGHT.
SB THREE NINETY ONE CLARIFIES
THE AUTHORITY OF A PERSON
EMPLOYED AS A SPECIAL
INVESTIGATOR BY THE BUREAU OF
HOUSEHOLD GOODS AND SERVICES.
THE ISSUE A WRITTEN NOTICE TO
APPEAR IN COURT FOR MISDEMEANOR
VIOLATIONS.
THIS BILL ALLOWS THE BEER OF
HOUSEHOLD GOODS AND SERVICES
AFFECTED WE PROTECT CONSUMERS
AND ASK YOUR AYE VOTE MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS I HAVE -- AS A
WITNESS ONLY TO COMMENT IF WE
NEED TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE --
DENNIS CUEVAS ROMERO DEPUTY
DIRECTOR OF THE DIVISION OF
LEGISLATIVE AFFAIRS WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER AFFAIRS
HE'S HERE ONLY FOR TECHNICAL.
CENTER THANK YOU THANK DENNIS
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE ARE
THERE ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
THE NINE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
CNN WILL BRING THE MATTER BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS.
SCENE NINE I THINK A SENATOR
DODD YOU AT A MOTION -- TO THIS
BILL -- IF THEY'RE MEANT TO THIS
[inaudible]
NO TECHNICAL [inaudible]
GOING WHERE.
US TO DO PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS TO PUBLICLY.
USE ME TO PASS THE PUBLIC SAFETY
ALL RIGHT WITHOUT.
CALL THE ROLL.
GLAZER AYE GLAZER I'VE CHANGED.
CHIANG AYE ARCHULETA.
ARE CHIRLA I THOUGHT.
DODD AYE GALGIANI.
DANNY AYE HILL.
WELL I LEYVA I LIVE AYE PAN WILK.
HI THAT BILL A CURLY HAS ENOUGH
VOTES TO GET APPLE WILL HOLD THE
ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU
MEMBERS THANK YOU AGAIN FOR YOUR
PATIENCE SENATOR.
IS A SENATOR PAN HERE.
AB A LETTER NOW WE CAN WE CAN
HAVE GO WITH THIS BILL IF HE'S
HERE
.
HI WE'RE GONNA OPEN THE ROLE IN
SB THREE NINETY ONE MINE.
THAT MOTION IS THE PASSAGE OF
THE PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE
CRIME BUT SEVEN ZERO PAN HI.
CAN I WILL I WILL DIE ALL RIGHT
THAT BILLS OUT -- NINE ZERO ALL.
WE WELCOME.
THE NEXT NINE MEMBER COMMITTEE
MEMBER WHO IS HERE.
SENATOR MITCHELL WELCOME SB SIX
THIRTY NINE JUST GOT IN JUST IN
TIME.
WE WELCOME YOU HERE.
I APPRECIATE YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER CHAIR AND COLLEAGUES.
TODAY ON PRESENTING BILL SIX
THREE NINE A MEASURE THAT WILL
INCREASE IN STRENGTH IN CONSUMER
PROTECTION SURROUNDED MEDICAL
CREDIT CARD THAT ARE OFFERED TO
PATIENTS.
BY MEDICAL PROVIDERS.
QUICK BACKGROUND ON THE ISSUE IN
TWO THOUSAND NINE AND ASSEMBLY
BILL ARE REQUIRED DID JUST TO
GIVE NOTICES PRIOR DECIDED TO
PATIENT FOR CREDIT CARD TO PAY
FOR MEDICAL SERVICES.
I CARRY BILL AND FOURTEEN WHICH
EXPANDED THESE RULES TO IN THE
LIFE OF HEALTH CARE PROVIDER.
WHILE THE LAW DOES PROVIDE FOR
BASIC PATIENT NOTIFICATION
CONSUMERS -- ARE STRUGGLING WITH
THE CONCEPT AROUND DEFERRED
INTEREST IN THAT THERE IN LIES
THE PROBLEM.
PATIENTS ARE SHOCKED AFTER
LEARNING ABOUT THE HIGH INTEREST
RATES OF THEIR REQUIRED TO PAY.
AFTER ACCEPTED THEIR RECEIVING
SERVICES MANY OF THESE PRODUCTS
ARE MARKET WITH AN INTRODUCTORY
PERIOD OF ZERO INTEREST.
FULL BUT THE PROBLEM LIES IN THE
WAY IN WHICH THE INTEREST IS
APPLIED SO FOR EXAMPLE A
CONSUMER CAN GET CAUGHT OFF
GUARD WITH THEIR FINANCED A
THOUSAND DOLLARS AND PAY OFF
NINE HUNDRED WITH AN
INTRODUCTORY PERIOD.
BUT IT DIDN'T HIT WITH THE 27%
INTEREST RATE CHARGE NOT ON THE
REMAINING ONE HUNDRED DOLLARS
BUT ON THE ORIGINAL ONE THOUSAND
DOLLAR -- EXPENSE WHILE MOST
CONSUMERS EXPECT THAT INTEREST
TO RISE SIGNIFICANTLY AFTER THE
INTRODUCTORY PERIOD.
HE YOU UNDERSTAND THAT MOST OF
THESE PRODUCTS CONTAIN THIS
DEFERRED INTEREST PROVISION.
SO WE'RE HOPING TO PROPOSE A
SOLUTION BEFORE YOU TODAY SB
THREE SIX THREE NINE ADDRESSES
THESE ISSUES BY DOING THE
FOLLOWING FIRST PROHIBITS
MEDICAL PROVIDERS FROM OFFERING
PRODUCTS WITH DEFERRED INTEREST
PROVISIONS.
SECONDLY IT PROHIBITS MEDICAL
PROVIDERS FROM CHARGING TO
MEDICAL CREDIT CARD SERVICES NOT
YET RENDERED.
THIRD IT REQUIRES PROVIDERS THAT
ACCEPT MEDICARE OUT TO EXPLAIN
TO MEDI CAL PATIENTS ONLY WHAT
MEDI CAL DOES AND DOES NOT COVER.
AND IT DOESN'T REQUIRE THAT ALL
THEIR PATIENTS GET THAT SAME
EPLANATION AND FINALLY IT
REARWARDS DISCLOSURE STATEMENT
FOR THE SERVICES TO A LEVEL THAT
IS MORE.
UNDERSTANDABLE AND APPROPRIATE.
WE UNDERSTAND WE WERE APPROACHED
BY THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION THE FLAG TO TACKLE A
TECHNICAL MEMBER TO CLARIFY THE
AGAIN THE LANGUAGE WITH ONLY --
BE MADE AVAILABLE TO MEDI CAL
PROVIDERS WE'RE MORE THAN
WILLING TO ACCEPT THAT LANGUAGE
THE BILL AS YOU KNOW MISTER
CHAIR IT'S BEEN DOUBLE REFER TO
CITY JUDICIARY COMMITTEE SO
WE'RE MORE THAN HAPPY TO MAKE
THE CHANGES BEFORE IT GETS TO
THE NEXT COMMITTEE.
ALL THIRD PARTY FINANCING IS
INDEED BENEFICIAL WHEN PATIENTS
NEED SERVICES THAT THEY CAN'T
IMMEDIATELY AFFORD MORE NEEDS TO
BE DONE TO PROTECT CONSUMERS
WHICH WAS BEAUTIFULLY LAID OUT
IN THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS.
ARE WITH ME HERE TODAY WE'VE GOT
CHEN FLORI WHO REPRESENTS THE
SPONSOR OF THE BILL THE WEST IS
THERE A LONG POVERTY -- POVERTY
AND ALLEN BOY THIS YOU SEE HERE
YEAH OKAY.
WHO'S A MEDICAL CREDIT CARD
CONSUMER I ASK FOR YOUR AYE
ABOUT.
THANK YOU SENATOR -- CHEN WE
LOOK FOR YOUR TESTIMONIAL NOTE
THAT -- THIS BILL DOES ENJOY
BROAD BASED SUPPORT NO
OPPOSITION AT THE MOMENT THAT WE
WELCOME YOU OKAY THOUGHTS ARE
WITNESS ALSO BE ALLEN TO BE HERE
IN A SECOND TO SHARE HIS STORY
BUT FIRST -- GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR AND MEMBERS I'M CHEN FLORA
THE WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY WESTERN CENTER WAS A
SPONSOR OF THE ORIGINAL
LEGISLATION AB ONE SEVENTY ONE
AND TWO THOUSAND NINE AFTER
HEALTH CONSUMER ALLIANCE
PARTNERS.
WHO OFFER FREE CONSUMER
ASSISTANCE TO THE STATE REPORTED
A NUMBER OF CASES CONSUMERS WHO
HAD SIGNED UP FOR MEDICAL CREDIT
CARDS THINKING THEY'D ENTERED
INTO A PAYMENT PLAN WITH OUR
DENTISTS?
DESPITE THAT LAW AND SENATOR
MITCHELL'S EXPANSION OF IT IN
TWENTY FOURTEEN WE CONTINUE TO
SEE PROBLEMS WITH HOW MEDICAL
CREDIT CARDS ARE PROVIDED TO
CONSUMERS ESPECIALLY LOW INCOME
CONSUMERS -- IN ONE MOMENT MR
BORN THIS YEAR'S GOING TO TELL
YOU SPECIFICALLY ABOUT THE
PROBLEM THAT HE HAD WITH
DEFERRED INTEREST BUT I'M GOING
TO GO THROUGH SOME OF THE OTHER
ISSUES THAT WERE SEEN -- OKAY
KEEP IN MIND THAT I THINK THIS
BILL HAS BROAD SUPPORT ON THE
COMMITTEE HAS OUT AND YOU'RE
WELCOME DISABILITY TO TESTIMONY
IN WRITING THAT EVERY WILL SHARE
WITH EVERYONE.
YES LET HIM [inaudible]
THANK [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU CHAIR AND SENATORS OF
PLEASURE TO BE HERE TODAY.
I'M ALLEN POINT AS A PRIVATE
CITIZEN FROM LAGUNA BEACH. FOUR
YEARS AGO I NEEDED A NUMBER OF
DENTAL PROCEDURES.
AND CONSIDERING THE EXPENSE AND
AMOUNT OF WORK MY DENTIST
RECOMMENDED FINANCING WITH THE
CARECREDIT PROGRAM OFFERED
THROUGH SYNCHRONY BANK.
I CARE CREDIT LOOKED ATTRACTIVE
AS EXPLAINED IF I MADE ALL MY
PAYMENTS ON TIME AND THE BALANCE
IS PAID OFF.
BY THE END OF THE PROMOTIONAL
PERIOD ALL INTEREST WOULD BE
WAIVED.
SO SYNCHRONY BANK CLOSES
DEFERRED INTEREST.
BUT THE FOR DISPATCHES MEAN
CHARGING INTEREST ON THE BALANCE
OF THE LOAN NOT PAID OFF DURING
THE PROMOTIONAL PERIOD.
RATHER THEY BACK CHARGE INTEREST
ON THE ENTIRE ORIGINAL IM
MAPPED.
WITH COMPOUNDED INTEREST ON THE
INTEREST AND THAT IS REGARDLESS
OF WHETHER THE BALANCE IS PAID
DOWN OR NOT DURING THE
PROMOTIONAL PERIOD.
ON MY FIRST CARE CREDIT BILL WAS
FOR THIRTEEN HUNDRED EIGHTY
EIGHT DOLLARS.
I PAID Vì AT LEAST THE MINIMUM
EVERY MONTH WHICH LEFT ME WITH A
BALANCE OF SIX HUNDRED DOLLARS
AT THE END OF THE TWELVE MONTH
PROMOTIONAL PERIOD.
AFTER PROMOTIONAL PERIOD MY BILL
WAS A STICKER SHOCK IT WAS UP
NINE HUNDRED AND FORTY NINE
DOLLARS ON A SIX HUNDRED DOLLAR
BILL.
SO I TRY TO DO THE MATH.
FIGURE OUT HOW SYNCHRONY
JUSTIFIED THREE HUNDRED FORTY
NINE DOLLARS IN INTEREST.
ON A SIX HUNDRED DOLLAR BALANCE.
AND AFTER TWELVE MONTHS EVEN AT
TWENTY SIX POINT 99% INTEREST.
WELL TURNS OUT THE THREE HUNDRED
FORTY NINE DOLLARS ON THE SIX ON
YOUR BALANCE WOULD BE
INEFFECTIVE INTEREST OF A
WHOPPING FIFTY ONE POINT 7%.
AND I I CALLED SYNCHRONY TO
EXPLAIN AND JUSTIFY.
WHAT ARE WHAT THEY WERE DOING
BECAUSE OF WHAT'S WHAT I DID THE
MATH?
THEY TOLD ME THEY DO MATH
DIFFERENTLY IT'S YEAH NEWMAN HE
SAID THE THREE HUNDRED FORTY
NINE DOLLARS WAS CORRECT BASED
ON THE ORIGINAL BALANCE OF
THIRTEEN EIGHTY EIGHT SO I WAS
TOLD TO REVIEW THE THREE PAGE
CONTRACT THAT WAS GIVEN MOMENTS
BEFORE NOVA KAINE -- WITH DENTAL
PAIN.
BY THE WAY SOMEWHERE BURIED ON
PAGE TWO IN WHAT LOOKED LIKE SIX
POINT UNREADABLE FONTS WITH THE
EXPLANATION JUSTIFYING THE
CHARGES SO I ASKED THEM TO GIVE
ME A HYPOTHETICAL HI I GAVE THEM.
A HYPOTHETICALLY SAID SYNCHRONY.
IF I WAS RUSHED TO THE HOSPITAL
ON A HEART ATTACK.
AND I HAD A HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN BILLS.
AND PAY DOWN NINETY NINE
THOUSAND NINE NINETY NINE BEFORE
THE IN THE PROMOTIONAL PERIOD
LEAVING ONE DOLLAR LEFT
AFTERWARDS WITH THE TWENTY SIX
POINT 99% INTEREST BE.
THE ONE DOLLAR BALANCE OR ON THE
FOUR HUNDRED THOUSAND THE ANSWER
WAS ON A HUNDRED THOUSAND I SAID
OKAY.
SO.
I'M NOT A LAWYER.
BUT I THINK I KNOW WITHIN CITY
IS PREDATORY PRACTICES ARE ON
CARE CARE CREDIT PROGRAM REALLY
PRAISE ON THE VULNERABLE AT A
TIME OF MEDICAL NEED.
ON AND DENTAL CARE SO I DON'T
KNOW IF WE CALL A GREEDY OR
USURY OR JUST PLAIN RIP OFF BUT
I I CALLED ON AMERICANS TO
CHARGE ON INTEREST AND PRINCIPAL
PAID DOWN.
AND I WOULD APPRECIATE AND
RESPECT A YES VOTE THANK YOU AND
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE I IS
THE NEWEST HERO HAD ROOT CANAL
ON FRIDAY AND AND IT HAD NOTHING
TO DO WITH BILLS IT WAS REALLY
IT.
TOO BUT I'M I HOPEFULLY YOU'RE
DOING WELL ON THAT THE DENTAL
SIDE CHEN THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
FAVOR.
PLEASE COME UP TO THE MIKE IF
YOU COULD IDENTIFY YOURSELF.
GOOD AFTERNOON JACK RECORDER
WITH THE CALIFORNIA DENTAL
ASSOCIATION WE ARE SUPPORTIVE OF
THIS BILL THERE'S SOME TECHNICAL
CONCERNS THAT HAVE BEEN RAISED
WITH US VERY VERY RECENTLY WHICH
WE ARE.
SEEKING TO UNDERSTAND AND
WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR TO
ADDRESS AS NEEDED THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNON RONALD COLMAN
HERE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE UP
TO HELP ACCESS CALIFORNIA THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
YOUNG ANGLE FOR CONSUMER
FEDERATION OF CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT THANK YOU ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN FAVOR.
THERE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
I'D SEEN IT WILL BRING THE
MATTER BACK TO THE COMMITTEE FOR
COMMENTS QUESTIONS OR MOTIONS.
WELCOME TO THE BILL CENTER PAN
IS MOVE THE BILL SECRETARY WOULD
CALL THE ROLL THAT CENTER
MITCHELL WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
ACTUALLY I VOTE OKAY VERY GOOD.
MISSION IS TO PASS THE SENATE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE GLAZER BY
LASER EYE CHIANG.
CHING AYE ARCHULETA.
LET AYE DODD.
THOUGHT I GALGIANI JUDGE ANY AYE
HILL.
FILL AYE LEYVA [inaudible]
PAN.
RIGHT PAN AYE WILK HI GUYS.
THE BILL HAS A VOTE CELL WILL
LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS THANK YOU SAID INITIAL.
RIGHT SENATOR SKINNER I WANTED
TO GIVE YOU THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT KEEP IN MIND IF YOU WANT
TO DEFER TO AFTER FLOOR SESSION
YOU CAN -- BUT WHAT WOULD YOU
WHAT WOULD YOU PREFER.
OKAY VERY GOOD SO LET'S -- LET'S
CALL CENTERS GOODNESS GUNNERS
BILL.
AS BEFORE -- SEVENTY FIVE AS FAR
AS I NOTICE AND ENJOY ANY
OPPOSITION SO.
CENTER SKINNER YOU CAN BEGIN AND
THERE ARE SOME -- TO A MAN YES
AND THAT'S WHAT I WILL READ --
RESPONSE RETAIN REFINE MY
CONFINE MY REMARKS TO IS THAT I
AM ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEES
AMENDMENTS THEY WERE -- WELL
CONSTRUCTED.
AND I WILL ALLOW MY WITNESSES
AND SPORT IN OTHERWISE I ASK
YOUR AYE BOTH VERY GOOD THANK
YOU CENTERS SKINNER.
GOOD AFTERNOON SURE GLAZER
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS MICHAEL WHEELER I AM THE VICE
PRESIDENT OF POLICY FOR FLOW
KANA.
A CALIFORNIA BASED CANNABIS
SUPPLY CHAIN COMPANY WITH A
FOCUS ON SMALL FARM SON GROUND
REGENERATIVE WE CULTIVATED
CANNABIS AND CANNABIS PRODUCTS.
I'M PLEASED TO BE HERE WITH YOU
TODAY.
IN ORDER TO SUPPORT FOR SB.
FOUR SEVEN FIVE SB FOUR SEVEN
FIVE WOULD AUTHORIZE LICENSE TO
CANNABIS BUSINESSES TO CREATE
AND PROVIDE TRADE SAMPLES.
OF CANNABIS GOODS INTERNALLY
INTO OTHER LICENSED CANNABIS
BUSINESSES.
AS BEFORE SEVEN FIVE WOULD NOT
AMEND THE RETAIL TO CONSUMER
PROHIBITION ON FREE SAMPLES TO
CUSTOMERS.
IN MANY OTHER INDUSTRIES TRADE
SAMPLES ARE ROUTINELY USED TO
TEST QUALITY ENABLE PRODUCT
KNOWLEDGE.
IN INFORMAL TRANSACTION. FOR
YOUR BENEFIT.
THINK OF WINE FOR EXAMPLE WHERE
IN THE WINE MAKER REMOVES A
PORTION OF WINE AGING IN A
BARREL TO ASSESS QUALITY.
IF SHE WERE IN THE CAMPUS
INDUSTRY THAT ACTION WILL NOT
CURRENTLY BE ALLOWABLE.
OR CONSIDER THE COFFEE INDUSTRY
WHERE THE SMALL GROWER SENDS A
SMALL PORTION OF FRESHLY
HARVESTED BEANS TO A ROASTER FOR
COMPARISON.
WITH OTHER SMALL BATCH HARVESTS.
IF THAT COFFEE ROASTER WERE IN
THE CANNABIS INDUSTRY.
HE DOES NOT HAVE A PROCESS TO
ENABLE COMPARISON CROSS HARVEST
LOTS. TO DECIDE WHICH TO
PURCHASE.
AND LASTLY IN THE HEAVILY
REGULATED SECTOR OF ALCOHOL
DISTRIBUTION.
A DISTRIBUTOR IS ABLE TO BRING
NEW PRODUCTS SAMPLES TO RETAILER
WITH THE HOPE THAT AFTER
ASSESSING THE PRODUCT THEY WILL
PLACE AN ORDER IN STOCK THEIR
SHELVES.
IF THAT ALCOHOL DISTRIBUTOR WERE
IN THE CANNABIS INDUSTRY.
THEY WOULD NEED TO FIRST ASK THE
RETAILER TO PLACE AN ORDER. FOR
THE SAMPLE BEFORE TRANSPORTING
THAT SAMPLE TO THE RETAIL STORE.
CANNABIS IS HEAVILY REGULATED
THE STATE'S TRACK AND TRACE
PROGRAM FOR CANNABIS AND
CANNABIS PRODUCTS IS ABSOLUTELY
ABLE TO ACCOMMODATE THE CREATION.
OF A TRADE SAMPLE PROCESS FOR
CANNABIS BUSINESSES.
AND WHILE TESTING WELL
LABORATORY TESTING IS CRITICAL
TO CONFIRM CERTAIN VARIABLE
DETAILS ABOUT A CANNABIS HARVEST.
THERE IS SIMPLY NO SUBSTITUTE
FOR THE SENSORY ANALYSIS DURING
QUALITY ASSESSMENT.
THE SENSORY INTERACTION IS A
MAJOR DRIVER OF THE NEED FOR
TRADE SAMPLES AND I'M HERE TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE THANK YOU MICHAEL.
WE REQUEST RIVAL MICHAEL MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS
AMY JENKINS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CANNABIS INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION VERY PLEASED TO JOIN
FLOW KANA AND CONTINUE WOMEN'S
CO SPONSORING THIS BILL -- WE
BELIEVE VERY STRONGLY THAT TRADE
SIMPLE SHOULD BE PROVIDED TO YOU --
TWO OPERATORS FOR OUR ANTI
PURPOSES TO BETTER -- IN FOR
RETAILERS AND ALSO PROMOTES
SMALL AND NEW AND EMERGING
BUSINESSES SO WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL AND ENCOURAGE
RIGHT VOTE THANK YOU THANK YOU
AMY ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
HE'S GOT THE MICROPHONE.
NUMBER SEVEN FOUR ON THE HAVE
BEEN.
BECAUSE CAN YOU TURN ON THE
LIGHTS SUPPORT.
GOOD SAID LIKE SIR.
A MIXTURE MEMBERS EVAN QUARTER
ON BEHALF OF CONTINUE ON ONE OF
THE CO SPONSORS HERE IN SUPPORT
WOULD LIKE TO THANK.
YOU AND YOUR STAFF FOR YOUR WORK
ON THIS ISSUE AND RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AB THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON ERIN ORDERED ON
BEHALF OF THE CANNABIS
DISTRIBUTION ASSOCIATION IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
INTERVIEW GRABS DEAN CHIEF
COMPLIANCE OFFICER FOR NOR CAL
CANNABIS -- STRONGLY SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
SABRINA FREDERICK WITH BERKELEY
PATIENTS GROUP STRONGLY SUPPORT
THANK YOU -- CHAIRED COLOR WITH
UNITED CAMAS BUSINESS
ASSOCIATION IN STRONG SUPPORT I
FEEL IT'S VERY NECESSARY THAT
RETAILERS THANK YOU VERY MUCH
YOU.
TOO THANK YOU ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN FAVOR SEEN ON ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
CNN WILL BRING THE MATTER BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE ANY QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS.
CENTER GALGIANI IS NO THE BILL
CENTERS CAN WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE -- SENATOR GALGIANI MOVED
THE BILL CENTERS CAN WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE.
VERY GOOD.
SECRETARY.
AS AMENDED THANK YOU MISSION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO GOVERN
FINANCE COMMITTEE GLAZER AYE
GLAZER AYE CHIANG.
CHING AYE ARCHULETA.
OUR CHAT I DOT.
DOT AYE GALGIANI GALGIANI AYE
HILL.
HELLO I LEYVA [inaudible]
PAN.
WILK RIGHT OKAY THAT WASN'T
RELUCTANT EITHER ALL RIGHT THE
BILL AT CURRENTLY ENJOYS ENOUGH
VOTES TO GET OUT SENATOR WE'RE
GONNA HOLD THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS THANK YU VERY
MUCH.
ALL RIGHT WE DIDN'T GET TO OUR
FULL AGENDA SO MEMBERS I HAVE TO
ASK YOU COME BACK FOR A COUPLE
BILLS.
AFTER SESSION TODAY SO WITH THAT
WILL BE IN RECESS RIGHT.
THAT THERE'S NO OF THOSE OTHER --
ANY.
WHO IS MISSING?
I'M NOT.
ANYTHING ELSE.
IS CLOSE AT HAND.
OKAY WHAT WHAT NUMBERS AT ONE
HEAD OF THE FOR THE ITEM ONCE
LET'S ARE RE OPEN SB.
THIRTY FOUR THAT MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO SAN
APPROPRIATIONS.
KRAVITZ EIGHT ZERO CHIANG.
CHIANG AYE. NINE THERE ARE THAT
BILLS OUT NINE ZERO OKAY WE'RE
GONNA BE AN THIS IS THE CENTER
PANEL LAST.
ONE LEYVA CAN'T THAT LABEL BUT
YOU CAN STILL PRESENT ONE HAND
ABOUT SOMEBODY -- REASON FOR HIM.
JUST ONE SECOND.
OKAY WITH THE DISCRETION OF THE
A COMMITTEE M COLLEAGUES WERE
GONNA ASK SENATOR PAN TO PRESENT
SB.
TWO SEVENTY FIVE BY TEN TO WOULD
BE TO SEE IF WE CAN MOVE ACT ON
THIS BILL IN FAVOR OR AGAINST.
AND THEN WE'LL COME BACK OUT.
AFTER SESSION TO UPHOLD THE ROLE
OPEN FOR ANY ABSENT MEMBERS OF
THAT WILL DEAL.
THE LAST CENTER CAN YOU WANT TO
PRESENT I THANK YOU YES MR
MEMBERS I BRING YOU SB TWO
SEVENTY FIVE WHICH WOULD ADD
SEXUAL BEHAVIOR -- WHICH IS
INCLUDE INAPPROPRIATE ACTIONS
COMMUNICATIONS OF A SEXUAL
NATURE PRECURSORS TO OURS A
HARMFUL AS A SEXUAL CONTACT WITH
A CLIENT OR FORMER CLIENT TO THE
LIST OF VIOLATIONS OF REQUIRE
ADMINISTRATIVE LAW JUDGES.
PROPOSED DECISION TO INCLUDE AN
ORDER OF REVOCATION I WILL GO
THROUGH THE DEFINITION BASICALLY --
I HAVE THE WITH ME THE BOARD OF
PSYCHOLOGY PRESIDENT -- DOCTOR
STEPHEN.
THERE'S EVEN A PHILLIPS.
AND SPEAK ON THE BILL BUT
ESSENTIALLY -- WITHOUT THIS --
THEY CONTACT SEXUAL CONTACT
INCLUDES GETTING A CLIENT
TOUCHING AND APPROACH THE LEASE
AND EXPLOITATION SUCCESS SIX
SESSIONS SEXUALLY IS A CUSTOMER
SEXY TO EXPOSE THE TAX.
SENATE CLIENTS BUT IS INCLUDING
A NEW TO GELS HERE'S BRIAN FINE
I'D LIKE TO ASK CENTER OUT
DOCTOR IF YOU WANT TO SPEAK
BILLABLE FOR QUESTIONS THAT BE
ALRIGHT.
OKAY ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
FAVOR.
AMANDA LEADER THAT CALIFORNIA'S
PSYCHOLOGICAL ASSOCIATION JUST
WANTED TO KNOW THAT WE ARE
NEUTRAL ON THE BILL IT DOESN'T
SAY SO IN THE COMMITTEE NOW SAYS
THERE'S NOT ROOM FOR ABOUT WE
ARE NEUTRAL WE WORKED THANK THE
BOARD FOR WORKING VERY GOOD ANY
OTHER WITNESSES IN FAVOR ANY
WITNESSES IN.
OPPOSITION.
ART SCENE NOW WILL BRING IT BACK
TO THE KENNEDY CENTER HEALTH
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I JUST
WANT TO SAY IT IT'S GREAT THAT
THE THIS LIKE THE PSYCHOLOGY
BOARD IS TAKING THIS ACTION
SUGGESTED IN MOVING FORWARD WITH
IT I WOULD JUST.
IT'S UNFORTUNATE THAT OTHER
BOARDS HAVE NOT DONE THAT AND
TAKING THE SAME ACTIONS SAME
STAND ON THE SAME CIRCUMSTANCES
SO I HAVE A GREAT DEAL OF
RESPECT AND GRATITUDE FOR THAT
MOVING THANK YOUS SENATOR
PAMPERED WITHOUT MOVE THE BILL
ARE AT THE BILL'S BEEN MOVED YOU
WANNA CLOSE SENATOR.
PAN.
OKAY THEN LET'S CALL THE MOTION
IS TO PASS THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE GLAZER
AYE GLAZER AYE TING.
TING AYE ARCHULETA VIRTUAL AND
AYE DODD.
DODD AYE GALGIANI JIN AYE HILL.
HILL AYE LEYVA.
HAND BY HAND I WILL.
ARTS CENTER PAN THAT HAS ENOUGH
OF THOSE TO GET OUT WE'RE GONNA
HOLD THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS SO WE'RE GONNA GO IN
RECESS NOW WILL COME BACK AND
FOR THOSE WHO HAVE -- ARE OFF
THE VOTES THAT ONLY FOR THE
PURPOSES OF ADDING ON BOTH THE
END OKAY.
THAT'S CORRECT IF YOU VOTER ON
EVERYTHING YOU DON'T NEED TO
COME BACK
YEAH THE P. AND
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT COMMISSION
COMMITTEE BACK TO ORDER WE HAVE
A COUPLE ROLES OPEN SO LET'S
START WITH WHICH BILL.
NUMBER THREE ITEM NUMBER THREE
SB TWO SEVENTY FIVE PAN THE
SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL LEYVA HI
LIVE I'D.
THE BILL IS OUT.
NINE ZERO BY TWENTY ITEM NUMBER
FIVE SB FOR SEVENTY FIVE SKINNER
SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL.
LEYVA ALRIGHT LEYVA AYE PAN.
OKAY ALL RIGHT THEY'RE GONNA
CLOSE THE ROLE IN THAT THAT
BILLS OUT.
EIGHT ZERO ITEM NUMBER EIGHT SB
SIX THIRTY NINE BY SENATOR
MITCHELL SECRETARY TO OPEN THE
ROLE LEYVA HI LEYVA I'D.
THAT BILLS OUT NINE ZERO SECOND
WITH OUR BUSINESS AT HAND VERY
GOOD THANK YOU EVERYONE THE
COMMITTEE IS ADJOURNED